a new report published by msn.com
says that according to a source Jaime
Fox was left paralyzed and blind from a
blood clot in his brain after receiving
the covid-19 vaccine now the family
contradicts this they say that Jamie
Foxx was playing pickleball and
everything's fine
well this guy uh who used to be a
communist for the New York daily news
says that's not true and they're lying
so of course this is trending on Twitter
it's become a big subject of debate so
we must talk about it and obviously
everybody has their opinions on the
vaccine and all that stuff but uh I
think it is worth important uh worth
worth noting and looking into the news
and the story considering this is a very
high profile celebrity who was working
on a big movie had appeared in
Spider-Man and a couple different
Spider-Man movies more recently so of
course this is a big subject subject of
controversy considering the celebrity
and the vaccine but we'll talk about it
and as we always like to say talk to
your doctor about what's right for you
because we're not medical professionals
here we do have a lot more big news
considering medical professionals in
need Joe Biden took a pretty serious
fall
I felt kind of bad when I saw it he he
he fell straight to the ground it looked
bad for someone his age that could be
pretty serious they're saying he's fine
even Trump said I hope he's all right
and yeah I don't like the bidens I think
they're nasty people but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna laugh at it this is a sad
man when he runs up the stairs and he
trips we chuckle it's like ah he's like
because we know he's fine but this fall
on stage was really bad and I when I saw
that I was like oh man like we look like
broken hip or something like for real
not not funny I mean some people are
probably laughing at it and then we've
got another big story The Daily wire was
set to release what is a woman on
Twitter and they were censored they
posted two tweets explaining it showing
this video
those tweets were censored Elon musk's
claims that it was a a mistake and
they're going to be fixing it and there
will be some limitations based on
Advertising but it will be allowed
however according to a few people
they're tweeting about
what's going on apparently they're
they're their new head of safety may
have resigned we don't have confirmation
we're hearing these rumors and there's
also rumors that when they when they
banned what is a woman Elon Musk was
actually in the room that's what they're
claiming ow I just can't believe it I
can't believe Elon Musk would buy
Twitter because of the Babylon B getting
banned over misgendering and then being
a room be like no misgendering it just
literally doesn't make sense so we're
gonna get into all this news but before
we do my friends head over to
castbrew.com
buy our coffee to support our work
Casper is our coffee company and we got
this really cool bag of coffee right
here look at that cast brew and uh I
gotta say man
it really is good I think I am I am
actually impressed with the team and
everybody who came together to to help
uh Source this coffee produce it and
then I was uh lucky enough to taste it
and be like guys this is a really good
coffee let's let's sell lots of this
stuff so Appalachian nights rise of the
brutal Junior you can join the Casper
coffee Club we're sponsoring ourselves
because we don't want to rely on
corporations that hate us we don't want
to want to run the risk of getting
having our sponsors cancel on us or
anything like that so we're gonna we're
gonna build it from the ground up and
when you buy Casper coffee those
resources when you buy the coffee are
going towards building physical
locations that hopefully will create
cultural hubs in many different cities
where people can walk in the door order
their coffee and there on the big TV is
James O'Keefe doing a report there's
Stephen Crowder there's Tim cast and all
of your favorites so we can create
physical locations where people will be
exposed to our information in our
culture also don't forget to let me pull
this up actually head over to
timcast.com click that join us but and
become a member to support our work
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you
tonight just after this live show is
around 10 p.m it'll be live on the front
page of the website sign up to support
our work directly don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is Sarah Higdon thanks
for having me on Tim thanks for having
me back um yeah I'm Sarah Higdon I'm a
content creator I host a YouTube show
Monday nights at seven so I've missed
Tim cast because of that oh yeah I did
it because of you guys I don't want to
run into you you know oh you gotta do it
early yeah yeah so I I uh it's called
transform to Freedom Mr Hunter my name
is Sarah Higdon on YouTube and Rumble
I'm also a writer over at
post-millennial and human events where
you can go subscribe on Twitter now for
five dollars and get some behind the
scenes content right on we're big fans
of the post millennial I'm always
reading their articles and shouting them
out and then complaining about typos or
something and Libby who comes on the
show frequently will fix it or whatever
yeah thanks for hanging out should be
fun we have Josie the red-headed
libertarian hi everybody my name is
Josie I am the redheaded libertarian
over on Twitter and I also do outside
media work at dimcast.com so you can go
over there and smash that join us button
and support our work
and I am the magician they say a
magician that's lost their magic is just
called Ian you know that's the that's
the suffix there I get it yep awesome it
took like two seconds
yeah that was great it wasn't I didn't
make it up thanks for the joke hi
everyone let's get started hey Serge
what's happening yeah that was a good
one I was not expecting that at all
anyways answers.com uh I'm excited let's
do it all right let's jump into this
first story from msn.com Health shocker
Jamie Fox left quote paralyzed and blind
from blood clot in his brain after
receiving covid-19 vaccine Source claims
now right there those two words should
send off alarm bells for you because I
don't know who this source is but what
we have is basically a calmness formerly
of the daily I believe the New York
daily news the New York daily news
saying that his Source has confirmed to
him these things so it is a reporter
saying I have a source
that's never usually good enough for me
to be completely honest so take this out
with a grain of salt Jamie Foxx's family
claimed that he actually was recovering
in and out of the hospital and was
playing pickleball so paralyzed and
blind is a bit extreme and I want to so
I see this story trending and I just
want to say be careful with it because
if you run out the door and I say haha
it's true because it's tens of thousands
of people tweeting about this
and then a week from now he shows up and
he's like man you all are crazy like
there's none of this is happening you're
gonna look really dumb yeah partial
paralyzation and blindness is possible
too like a little bit of loss of ocular
ability and maybe it's harder to move an
arm but he could still get up and play
Pickleball so it's possible that all
three yeah true dude could have crapped
his pants you know what I mean like what
we heard about it is that he was on the
set of a film he had some kind of
medical episode and he's been in and out
of the hospital so it's been very
secretive and just like that football
player remember that guy who Tamar
Hamlin yeah he fell down in the field
and everyone's like oh he's he's he's
paralyzed or whatever and then sure
enough he literally shows up on TV
totally fine you had fetterman they
reported that he was completely he was
reportedly brain dead and he's back I
mean he's still having he's still
struggling and everything but he's as he
was before he went to the hospital too
I'm not saying it's not true I'm just
saying be careful with this stuff take
it with a grain of salt and uh talk to
your doctor about what makes sense for
you find good doctors don't rely on the
internet for medical information but uh
I do think the story is still very uh
interesting and because it's trending I
think we should talk about it so we have
this story they say horrific an end to
stress this point I want to make sure
everyone at YouTube and all the Liberals
and all the leftists and all the big
Pharma sycophants see this this is
msn.com reporting this and they are
certified by newsguard 100 out of 100 so
if I can't use this as a source I don't
know what to tell you because we're
gonna here you go
horrific Health details have have been
revealed regarding Jamie Foxx's
mysterious medical State the Django
Unchained star is said to be partially
paralyzed and blind in addition to a
series of other complications after
receiving the covid-19 vaccine Hollywood
journalist AJ benza claimed after
speaking to a source close to Fox quote
Jaime had a blood clot in his brain
after he got the shot he did not want
the shot but the movie he was on he was
pressured to get it confessed The
podcaster Who formerly worked as a
columnist for the New York daily news as
well as the host of the E-Series
Mysteries and Scandals during an
appearance on Dr Drew pinsky's online
show ask Dr Drew
quote the blood clot in the brain caused
him at that point to be partially
paralyzed and blind benza alleged as he
insisted his Insider was someone in the
room with first-hand knowledge of Fox's
hospitalization I am thinking is that
why he blew up on the set a week before
his medical emergency happened the
veteran journalist asked Pinsky is that
why he fired three or four people
because he has had it with these
mandates Fox was admitted to the
hospital after suffering a medical
complication on Thursday April 11th
although specific details on his current
health status have been difficult to
discover
the 55 year old's medical woes mounted
while filming his latest movie Back In
Action the movie also starring Cameron
Diaz has moved forward with production
without Fox using a body double in his
place so they do go into stress
that uh his daughter Cory Corin or
Corrine said that he was playing
pickleball saying sad to see how the
media is running wild my dad has been
bent out of the hospital for weeks
recuperating in fact he was playing
pickleball yesterday thanks for everyone
prayers and support we have exciting
work and now uh work announcement coming
next week
so this guy then says it's all lies in
baloney if you read into what they were
saying early on quote he is
communicating with us that doesn't mean
talking that could mean anything writing
sign language I know those little code
words benza continued to assume Fox's
current capabilities then you tell me
your father is playing pickleball give
me a break there's a great shot of
secrecy around Jamie Foxx so we don't
know right what we do know is I think we
have uh TMZ reported he's doing physical
rehab in Chicago family by his side and
we don't know exactly why but they why
he's at the facility what his medical
issue was they say well we don't know
exactly what happened to Jaime or why
he's there we know the facility
specializes in stroke recovery traumatic
brain injury rehab spinal cord injury
rehab and cancer Rehabilitation they say
there's no reason to believe that he has
cancer but to be completely honest if
we're just doing if we're just
speculating at this point maybe his
medical episode is related to cancer and
honestly I have no idea but uh welcome
to Big celebrity news trending on
Twitter what happened and I want to
throw in there Eric Clapton real quick
who uh his hands were partially
paralyzed and he freaked out after he
got the vaccine so I don't know what you
guys think
uh I think that if they have a body
double in the movie then he's got some
serious health issues at the moment
otherwise they wouldn't have had to get
a body double to do the job well he's
clearly I mean his daughter is saying
what he's out of the hospital now yeah
yeah if he's if he's able to play
Pickleball he would be able to star in
the movie though so that that whole
pickleball narrative doesn't make sense
if they have a body double for him for
the movie and the fact that they're
saying that he's in rehab whether for
whatever reason yeah I think that
there's something going on maybe it's
not necessarily the kova jab related but
it could be something else I mean it's
something there's something in the
language that makes it sound like yeah
he could have had a blood clot and he
could have had paralyzation but now he's
recovering from it so no he doesn't have
that because they could have fixed it I
mean the language is interesting the way
that the article's written and the way
that the daughter talks about it sounds
like something bad happened they've
fixed it and he's recovering from it so
no he technically doesn't have that you
know currently right now at this moment
playing pickleball I mean I'm looking at
the things that this place specializes
and if you have a spinal cord injury
you're not playing pickleball so that
leaves the other serious things so
unless and and it's just what two weeks
of rehab and then he was back to playing
pickleball or is he like in a wheelchair
with one arm slumped over yeah
what is pickleball anyway oh yeah it's
like it's kind of it's something old
people play ah this is uh I play
Pickleball combined some elements of
tennis badminton and table tennis no I
do I love playing pickleball we play at
the gym um it is kind of like a table
it's like a table tennis mixed with
tennis but it's a smaller quarter and
like beach tennis almost
I've never played Beach tennis like that
yeah it's those big wooden paddles right
it's small well it's really small
paddles and you actually play with like
a wiffle ball and you can get those
things moving though I think I've seen
this yeah like I've seen this it's just
a smaller smaller court but you gotta
move and even if you're playing doubles
you gotta move do you do you do that at
the home Sarah
no I do it at the gym it's possible that
Jamie Fox loves pickleball and that in
his recovery wants to get out there and
play even if he's playing poorly just to
get his motor skills it's just blowing
again what if he's like in a wheelchair
and he's just like slumped over and they
put the pickleball thing in his hand and
he's not moving and they're like he's
playing dude he's one of my favorite
actors man this is Horror Story yeah I
thought he was gray and Spider-Man to be
honest and then and then everything he
does is turns to Gold he's playing Ray
Charles did you guys oh my God that was
brilliant I've only seen Clips but good
Lord the man's amazing amazing I am
Wanda from In Living Color I was
watching some Keenan Ivory Wayans
earlier today even his music his music's
fantastic too he's trained pianist he
went to college for a piano wow that's
why he could email the audition Ian
really likes there's a show called The
Masked Singer where they have people
dress up and like like furries and Sam
and um the every single year that they
have this every single person who's a
male that sounds amazing thing that
sings they're like that's Jamie Foxx you
know that's that's how that's like
that's their person it's almost like a
running joke now at this point that he's
definitely got the voice I've got like
this love I remember on In Living Color
I don't know if you guys watched it in
the beginning 19 late 80s or something
he came on as the new guy like in the
second or third season and he was like
the kind of the outsider had to figure
out am I even funny everyone's like who
is this guy he's a joke and then he made
that Wanda character where it was like
that cross-eyed woman with the blonde
wig he's playing and he's always like
Tommy Lee Davidson's like ah you know he
wants to make out
um and after that he won my heart and it
was like just just this is the new guy
you know he overcame being the new guy
to become one of the greats of all time
I love you Jamie oh I mean the the going
blind after playing Ray Charles is a
little bit uh
I I really do think this is a strong
possibility he's gonna show up in like a
week completely fine I hope so and I
feel like dude this gossip stuff was
click bait whenever somebody goes goes
private for whatever reason then people
just run run whatever they can because
it's going to generate traffic and uh
you know we were actually thinking do we
which medical story do we run Joe Biden
collapsing on stage and uh you know fall
he tripped on the sandbag I guess or
Jamie Foxx and it's just like this story
is is picking up steam because it hits
all those buzzwords it's got everything
it's got a celebrity it's got a movie
being shut down it's got covid
vaccination it's got mysterious illness
so everybody wants to know what's
happening and then everyone's giving you
the most Sensational output possible and
I'm like
maybe but don't be surprised if in a
week he comes out and he's like man
y'all are crazy I hope he does yeah I
want to be wrong but think about how you
let it off though too this is the
mainstream media so it's and they're
running you know anti-covet vaccines
which is the exact opposite of what they
would have been doing a year ago so that
should give you some confidence that
that's possibly what's going on it could
be some kind of damage control that
they're laying I don't know but remember
and remember when that when the football
player collapsed remember they had
somebody show up to the stadium and he
was like all like dressed in you never
even saw his face oh they did the waving
from the window same thing that's why
I'm saying I think a lot of this is
publicity stunts because Demar Hamlin
ended up doing a press conference
clearly discernably him not that long
afterwards and so what happens is two
things you discredit the conspiracy
theorists who are like ah we knew and
then all of a sudden he's like ah here I
am you're crazy and it's like oh you're
crazy I remember after the Demar Hamlin
thing I was I was hanging out and uh I
was out at the uh the poker tables and
the people they were like dude he was he
was just waving to the crowd what are
you talking about I didn't say anything
I didn't like I'm not someone who goes
out and be like did you hear the crazy
conspiracy here's what I believe I was
like what's going on with that Hamlin
thing like uh they're claiming that he
he's paralyzed or whatever or like he
fell down what happened with that and
they're like nothing's going on it's all
nonsense he was he was at the stadium
waving the people not that people are
crazy and I'm like uh how about that
that's what they thought but if you
watched the video you were like yo what
is this clearly not him yeah but then
later he comes out and you can clearly
see it's him so I I think that probably
was a publicity stunt they were like hey
here we'll do this now that he's sick
we're gonna get a lot of hits and we're
gonna boost his profile send out someone
to act all weird generate a ton of press
and conspiracies and then he comes out
and everything's fine so I wouldn't be
surprised not that Jamie Foxx needs
press to be completely honest yeah
seriously the only conspiracy thing I
can think of is if the people like I'm
not saying that they did this but some
company that had created uh coveted
vaccines is like all right let's see
this story where it makes it look like
the coveted vaccine's the bad guy but
then when they find out that it wasn't
the coveted vaccine we'll be off the
hook and then they'll think all these
other conspiracies about the vaccine are
all so bad we're wrong and we'll be off
the hook so seed bad info I don't think
that's what happened sounds like an
experiencing Theory but the whole like
injury after the covet vaccine does not
imply that the covet vaccine did this to
the guy it's rare it's worded in a way
that it kind of insinuates it but it
doesn't mean that no I'm not saying it
didn't but it doesn't
Hollywood celebrity gossip that people
want to latch on to people on the left
are saying like this is fake news you
shouldn't tweet it people on the right
are being like whoa this is reported by
this is being carried by MSN the
original reporting is Okay magazine but
MSN which is certified by News Guard 100
out of 100 must have checked it or
something or this is this is the kind of
stuff they put out so Microsoft news MSN
is that what that stands for Microsoft
news this is Microsoft and Microsoft
owns I think it's Microsoft network and
Microsoft owns uh the 100 fact check
msn.com is certified by newsguard 100
out of one Microsoft owns newsguard and
MSN they have a contract with them and
Bill Gates
I don't think Bill Gates is directly
involved with Microsoft oh yeah yeah but
so there it is I mean if the headline
says it and newsguard certified it I
don't know what else to tell you other
than you know make sure you're getting
sound medical advice from a good medical
professional pray for Jamie Foxx yeah
yeah absolutely and uh
Let's uh let's let's talk about another
very serious medical condition Joe
Biden's brain and body because he is in
um
he's facing very serious what is it
senescence is that is that the word
senescence senescence senescence yes uh
he's old yeah to to translate that
breaking Biden Falls during Air Force
commencement ceremony on video yeah this
was brutal when I saw this I'm gonna
let's let's let's make this a video big
so you can watch
call this crumpling to the ground
yo that was bad the reaction of
everybody oh and then he can't get up
did they cheer yeah they did that's
sharing somewhere somewhere I think they
screamed like I maybe they thought he
got shot or something but he doesn't
have the muscle Master lift himself up
see
screaming yeah
yeah took it bigger there there's
another oh this is another there are
other angles yeah really shows a girl
walking towards it watching him fall and
turning and walking away all the way we
just have him falling up the stairs Jack
besobic tweeted it earlier yeah let me
see if I can find uh pasobic's tweet
this is rough man this is the the
commander of our military any who's
having a hard time getting himself up
off the ground after he fell why did he
even fall
Dude Where's the like I said you can see
a black sandbag at the bottom of the
left and he points back at something
when they stand him back up too so he
did it does look like he tripped over
something but still anytime it's old
trips and falls it's never it can cause
serious issues
Trump's reaction here we go
he's at the Air Force Academy
he actually fell down
well I hope he wasn't hurt I hope he
wasn't hurt but it's the whole thing is
look the whole thing is crazy
you got to be careful about that you got
to be careful about that because you
don't you don't want that even if you
have to tip toe down a ramp
so funny man he's tight did you guys see
someone retweeted the old article from
CNN it was like why what do they call it
it's like why the ramp story matters and
it shows Trump walking it's it's like a
smooth metal ramp with rain on it yeah
what is Trump supposed to do running
slide down one of my favorite articles
everyone that's like this proves he has
Dimension then you watch something like
that and you're like he doesn't have to
mention he's he's throwing out bangers
yeah
okay let's let's be real I'm gonna play
this video for you guys one more time
I'm gonna uh we'll zoom in on it all
right
oh all right okay here's here's what I
want to highlight all right let's let's
get the slo-mo replay here he's he's
standing here look at his left leg his
left leg does not go up his right leg
goes forward and then he goes straight
down yeah so so his left leg either
tripped over something or he double
stepped or tripped over his own foot
this guy in the front is having the time
of his life this dude on the right
moment look at him ready yes he's like
yes I mean he just graduated so he's
getting commissioned and the president's
right there I mean you know oh my God he
is just living the dream right he's not
a good president but still it's got to
be feel good to be graduating and that's
the scene forever now but so here's
here's what I'm saying
you can argue oh there's a sandbag on
there's a there's a sandbag on stage or
whatever and it's like dude no no no no
no is there any video where we see the
ground yeah you can if you scroll
forward yeah okay there just a little
bit right there you see the black thing
on the bottom left corner okay right
there
you can see it right here why was there
a sandbag but why did he turn left and
just fall yeah I think it's an excuse I
think I think he just fell as an old man
oh and then he points like oh something
happened no no no no look look look look
was his right foot in the sandbag
already because look at his look at his
I'm sorry his left leg look at his left
leg it doesn't he goes forward actually
twists and then he's on it and then he
falls it almost looks like he was
propping his foot like his foot was on
the side of his foot was connected to
the sandbag and when he turned his foot
his leg never actually turned you can
see it I don't want it it's turning I
don't want to be too hard on him for
falling on stage I've fallen on stage in
fact at the Turning Point USA event
because if you don't do your diligence
before the performance and you don't
Scout the stage and get familiar with
where the pits are where the chords are
where the yeah and then lights are
behind you're looking at the audience
you've got Bright Lights yeah
um it can it can be dangerous so you got
to know stage presence but it's his
inability to get back up that really
concerns me oh yeah he tries to lift
himself up and can't and they have to
help him up yeah well that's what
happened when he fell on the stairs too
he was like kept getting blown around by
the by the wind he couldn't get back up
well when he fell up the stairs he got
back up real quick did he I thought yeah
numerous times okay yeah
numerous times
really fast yeah it could be
disorienting to you know if he'd just
fall in and like didn't really know what
happened and all of a sudden was on the
ground and trying to get his you know
and he's also obviously got dementia so
you know just trying to figure out from
there
like just being a person whose brain
isn't even all there like what just
happened trying to make his hands go in
the right place
I was thinking that the world ended on
December December uh 2012. because I'm
just like and I'm kidding by the way but
you know it really does feel like the
Mayans is what it was that prediction
was that the world that we knew ended
and that was and that's a good bit but
I'm thinking about how uh I can't
remember what was going on we were we
were hanging out somewhere and uh I
played I think I was playing Three Dog
Night
and then somebody said to me like oh
you're you're like playing the oldies
and I was like isn't that funny I don't
know what year was it through dark now
like late 60s yeah earlier and I'm like
if you were in a kid in the 90s and
someone put on three dog night it was
old yeah and it was 25 year old music
now I turned I go to a grocery store I
go to a restaurant and they're playing
Stone Temple Pilots on the Oldies
Channel and it's just like something
happened in our society where everything
just stopped being real the way we knew
it and maybe it's just because we didn't
live in those times
but like I look at this video here's why
I bring it up I look at this video and
I'm like there's there's no way this is
what the American Office of the
presidency was supposed to be right like
something doesn't make sense even Donald
Trump was weird like seriously you have
a conspiracy when they turned on that
Atom Smasher
opened a hole in the space-time
Continuum and Unleashed whatever the
hell has happened people think that the
Hadron Collider turning on triggered the
oncoming of Trump no it was Biden
it was like Trump was supposed to happen
because he's a he's a Maverick and he's
like Reagan in a certain sense but Biden
so when I when I see him fall here and
I'm like does no one around think
something is wrong like dude this is how
many times has he Fallen he's gonna have
him run again it's it I it feels like
everybody is standing around watching
The Naked Emperor walk down the street
and they're all like oh how wonderful
how amazing and I'm just like dude has
this country already fallen apart I
think they have control they have
whoever is really pulling the strings
because it is not him no no I I think
the opposite there's no control they're
like they're they're it's it's 2019
they're like what do we do what do we do
I don't know Trump's gonna win again
well they have Joe Biden he's like are
you crazy Joe I don't know what to do
he's a puppet of I I would think
honestly I mean if I want to go into my
other conspiracy about this it's a
puppet of who Obama I I just it's all
it's Obama's agenda and this was his
vice president and so he can't run three
terms
Hillary in 2016. yeah yeah so he's uh
he's the one pulling this that's my
that's my theory I could be wrong
possible I mean a lot of people think
that doesn't Obama live right by the
White House yes
but I I look at this and I just can't
believe there's any real organizing
Force I mean certainly there are people
with power but the Democrats have no one
the problem on the right right now is
that there's too many Trump and DeSantis
are too good they're both too good and
now people are like well Santa's is bad
no Trump is bad and it's like they're
both just really good and arguing about
who's better and then you've you like
look even Tim Scott is good and you know
Christy gnome is good I don't think
they'll win but there's a big lineup of
high profile people on the right yes
with two major contenders of course
Trump being the obvious front runner and
the Democrats side there's nothing
literal nothing Gavin Newsom but barely
and like Michelle Obama or Oprah yeah
but you know George solaro's son has
taken over his legacy as well and has
full access to the White House that came
out a couple months ago so he he visited
the White House a ton of times last year
so he's basically taken over his dad's
white house visits
George soros's son I'm just saying you
know when I bring up the music stuff
it feels like there was a cultural
cohesion to this country that things may
have been bad at some times there may
have been crime in like the 80s in New
York and all that stuff but there was a
cohesion to it now it feels like
everyone knows it's not real anymore
and it's it's all broken apart right
like how would you we could describe the
70s we can describe the 80s we can
describe the 90s we can describe the 60s
we can describe the 50s we can describe
the changes and when they were coming
into place we can talk about how in the
late 60s the clothing started changing
which became the dominant trends of the
70s and then the late 70s clothing
started changing and then we saw the
dominant trends of the 80s and you know
what like hot neon tiger striped hot
pants or whatever remind me and in the
90s with like you know flannels and
acoustic guitars or whatever jeans with
hip-hop and all that yeah and then the
2000s the 2010s and and the 2020s are a
blur of mangled nonsense I think that
was also the internet and so all of
these all of because the the the trends
used to come from
the coast and they'd move inward so like
Boston California you know those would
be the trendy places and they'd that's
where the trends would pick up and
they'd move inward but now we have the
internet where everybody gets everything
at the same time and all the trends are
shifting and everybody wants to be the
next big thing and what we get is a
show we get chaos so it all happens at
once yeah it's completely it's
information overload but I I mean what
you said earlier I think that there
should be an age limit to when you can
run for president run for Congress
everything like that I mean there's who
is it is it the congresswoman Dianne
Feinstein yes who was wheelchaired into
the she looks like the Crypt Keeper and
she asked Kamala Harris what are you
doing up here yeah when she was speaking
when she was presiding over the Senate
she's there to check the box I mean and
she's just I mean she doesn't know what
she's doing there yet she's casting
votes yes at the least a grip strength
test of grip strength because that's
like an indication of muscular atrophy
if you can't pick yourself up off the
ground I don't think you're fit to
command
um yeah let alone the mental stuff
that's a little more challenging of like
are you smart enough to do the job like
who tests for that and I mean you got to
look at honestly like like after 9 11.
George Bush like went to ground zero and
put his arm around the firefighters like
we're gonna do what you know and he was
just this force that everyone you know
felt safe watching after this horrible
event happened would you feel safe being
in the hands of Joe Biden after after
this awful event happened no no I feel
like I got to protect him yes exactly
that's your instinct you know just as a
human being like this is an elderly man
who's being exploited I was thinking a
couple days ago the United States it's
not really a country it's not a place
it's an idea of a bunch of states that
have decided to unite for the betterment
of all the states and we could
technically have that all over Earth
like we could have a Giants States
United across earth whatever the United
States there here we are now it's just
more States in action but this one man
it's it seems like the last 20 years
started to interrupt have been a bit
like you said earlier chaos I think you
mentioned that case I I don't know if
it's true through but there's that line
in National Treasure where I think it's
Nicholas Cage he says that before the
Civil War people would say the United
States are and then afterwards they
would say the United States is in these
United States yeah exactly because there
was an idea that the states were each
what they are 50 separate Sovereign
entities with a trade agreement is is
what the states are but then after that
it became really cohesive and it was
like one thing so where we are the
United States we are one entity and and
you you think about it like we the
states are really Blended together
people didn't really understand the
purpose of them because of civics not
being taught in schools and things like
that people didn't understand this so
now since covid we're getting
we're getting 50 separate states that
you can clearly identify like you're
going to go to Florida because they're
not going to give sex changes to
children not because it's sunny like
you're you're going there now because
the kids are safe you know you're not
you're not gonna go to California
because you want to see the Hollywood
Walk of Fame because you'll probably get
murdered you're going there now because
you want to visit Wine Country up north
where it's safe you know so so the way
that the states work now we see what
they were meant to work in it's a 10th
Amendment thing but it's really
interesting because yeah you see that
there's so many states that there's very
clearly different states and then we
have states with Sanctuary City policies
and Sanctuary estate policies to where
they won't even extradite criminals to
other states and so how are we a
cohesive United States
the only thing that we're not together
is that we have a large federal
government which is which is kind of the
antithesis of the 10th Amendment yes so
we are not a coach we are not what we
were anymore we are definitely
separating and this I think the way
forward is with strong states rights
I've always said this like we're not
going to have a national divorce we're
going to have strong states rights so
we're these 50 states are going to look
like 50 different countries is is my
idea of it like Florida is going to get
more Florida California is going to get
more California New York's going to get
more New York because of the voting
policies in these states that are not
going to allow really any any difference
you know especially in the blue states
where anybody can vote and stuff but
what we have to do is then shrink the
size of the federal government to create
the better absolutely we worry about the
supremacy clause when it comes to some
of the powers that they have um as
opposed to the 10th Amendment you know
Ron DeSantis can do a lot of stuff but
there's a few things that he won't be
able to do currency is another
indication of the of the I guess you
would call it the diffusal power of the
federal government because it used to be
the American dollar yeah but now we've
got crypto Constitution states can coin
money
that's what happened yeah why don't they
yeah well right exactly like hello like
has anybody read this document yeah the
Santa's bucks yeah exactly I would
invest so hard well you got to be
careful too because I think both parties
would want to go to a crypto base system
a digital Fiat and that's always a bad
idea oh yeah you don't want the federal
government doing it at all you don't I
wouldn't even want state government
appointing the money what about Florida
coin oh I would buy Florida coin would
you all buy Florida coin yeah I I would
local currencies are extremely important
and it's really really bad that we got
rid of them because what happens now is
if Florida had its own currency that
currency can't leave Florida meaning
economic activity remains within control
within Florida so so it'd be like
visiting Canada where you go in and you
trade in
by the local currency yeah and trade
exactly so here's what happens when you
have the national currency
a state like Michigan collapses when the
factory leaves because the money leaves
with it money is coming from an external
Source outside of Michigan into Michigan
it is spent by the people of Michigan on
things outside of Michigan if you have a
local currency you have more local
production more local farming more like
local uh trades work and things like
that and then if external sources of
revenue cease yes the economy may get
depressed to a certain degree but trade
still exists between people in that
state to solve their problems which is
why the U.S fares so much too because
with external trade with other countries
our our dollar is what everybody trades
with right and so we get rid of that if
they go off of something that else then
they have control over our production
this is why Bitcoin is great but if
there was state state level currencies
the federal government could not take
the tax resources of the people of
Florida and then send it to Pakistan for
gender studies unless you wanted to
trade out of state so the way you do
that is you have your US dollars every
state has their own crypto you go to
Florida sandwiches five bucks of US
dollars or 4.60 if you spend Florida
coin so I'll buy a bunch of Florida coin
when I get to Florida I'll get a
discount a seven percent discount on
everything I buy while I'm in Florida as
long as I stay within the state you've
created a local currency uh I guess you
could you could give the feds some some
portion of that tax so that keeps the
system flowing it's gonna say if federal
taxes are what kind of keeps everything
together so if you eliminate like
federal income taxes then you would be
fine because federal income taxes would
have to be paid in American federal
dollars and so you have to know what
you're paying in that and it would just
confuse a lot of stuff as well or you
could pay your income taxes with Florida
coin but you'll have to pay seven
percent more if you pay it in Florida
coin so you'd be encouraged to buy your
US Dollars back to pay your or just
whatever you pay your taxes that would
you pay the taxes in Florida coin and
the federal government can spend the
money in Florida or to anybody who wants
transactions with Florida and they can't
print more of it that's the thing right
if a state like Florida had its own
currency you you could be like oh I only
earn money in Florida currency but I'll
pay my taxes here you go government and
the government goes we can't print money
more of this so you get what you get
that's a good thing no more deficit no
deficit spending see this is the way the
founders knew what what a big powerful
government was capable of I mean the
reason we had the Boston Tea Party was
because the largest multinational
conglomerate in the world was hanging
out like like chummy it was crony
capitalism essentially it was hanging
out with the British government and they
they were told that any product that
they lose would be reimbursed they were
told they didn't have to pay any taxes
on their product and that it would all
it's all coming out of the states like
like this this happened before this is
why the Constitution's written the way
that it is like if if we have a decent
understanding of History so they knew
what it was capable of and they put in
safeguards throughout the Constitution
that would protect the states if there
ever became a massive federal government
again and one of those is Florida coin I
think we had uh Steven Marsh on the show
a while ago and he was saying that
there's a multicultural democracy in a
constitutional republic trying to exist
in the same space and I'm like I agree
with that and I hope you understand that
the Multicultural democracy is the
parasite that is growing within the
constitutional republic and subverting
and destroying it yes I think it's
trying to inhabit its body and wear it
like a cultural revolution that was like
Mal's journey and it's it's transfixed
itself into our country not through the
internet this this demo this this mob
rule this cultural mob rule where it
changes week to week like what was okay
to say last week is no longer okay now
this word's bad and you can't do this
because the mob says so and even though
it's legal if the mob gets angry about
it they're gonna put the put the guy
away that's not doing anything wrong for
his own protection because the mob like
no no we're Republic man we have Law and
Order yeah but I do think it's going to
get dark I really do think so I I think
there will come a time relatively soon I
say relatively because who knows how
many years it could be where like a
regular person is at their house they
have an American flag and then one day
to knock on the door and they're like
gonna help you and they're like take the
flag down or else now that's already
happened yeah in Portland and Seattle
but I'm saying there will be elements of
authority now knocking on your door
being like that's a hate symbol when you
see there was like there's like a viral
meme of uh military cadets or something
carrying the American flag but also
Pride Flags I'm like yeah that's a flag
of an ideology now the people here in
the United States however many of them
can look at that and be like oh how nice
and I'm like I I see that when I look at
that flag I see the same thing as a
swastika when I when I when I go to like
down on Frederick they have like they
have these flags with eagles on them and
things like that I'm like obviously I'm
not saying that this ideology is
identical to Nazism or anything like
that I'm saying it is a flag of an
ideology that is infecting the the
culture and being waved around over the
flag of the country the country is being
subverted so so uh when there's a
Marxist takeover the first thing that
they do is they have to um they have to
demonize nationalism and this is about a
20-year process for the study if you
think of when nationalism started being
demonized it's around Obama
administration when they first got in
that that's when they started demonize
so it's about a 20-year process and and
if you think about how like they started
adding the word white to the threat of
nationalism you know to to make it uh
egregious or Christian yeah Christian
the Christian nationalism so so these
are the things that that they do and I
support the culture I will say one thing
that gives me hope is that June of
course as you all know is American
greatness month yes and all of these
major corporations have started changing
their logos to the rainbow which of
course is God's covenant to life on
Earth never to flood the planet again
and so I was really surprised to see so
many companies just praising the Lord
wow that's really great I saw that I saw
it I saw GE put put that in there in
their uh bio um in America and I mean
I'm grateful because that is God's
agreement with the people and that's his
Covenant yes they didn't do it in Saudi
Arabia and I think maybe because of
Allah or whatever well America's a
Christian Nation so all of these
companies promoting being respectful to
other religions which I find just so
nice so sweet but is light pink light
blue white brown and black black is that
part of the rainbow now oh no that's
yeah that's that's that's that's
that's that's I see these ideological
flags being flown by governments and
agencies and I'm like yeah that's like
the swastika yeah that's that's not the
flag of our nation and there's no reason
to fly that flag at government
institutions yeah it's important to
remember the swastika was a beautiful
symbol when it first appeared in the mid
late 20s in Germany everyone was a very
hopeful sign of the wheel of life but
the inversion of it the Hindu symbol and
only when they became psychotic did it
gain a psychotic you know uh notation
next to it there's there's a building on
the south side of Chicago where I grew
up that everyone knows about it's a
house and it's because it's a it's a
two-story house and on the top of it
there is a square that looks like it's
it's like a a cross in a square right
but you can clearly tell that there are
wood blocks nailed to it because it was
actually a swastika I know where that's
going yeah but but people don't realize
this that I went to an antique store
when I was in Austin they had swastikas
everywhere and one of the guys who
worked there I was like I saw them and I
was like wow I was like you guys don't
get Flack for selling like
swastika banners and the guy showed me
his keychain he's like no I got like
three right here and I'm like I was like
really you're not worried about that and
he was like before the Nazis used it it
was all over the United States it was a
symbol of luck it was good good fortune
it's thousands of years old and then the
well the
the the inversion of it the original
symbol is facing otherwise which way
it's spinning but in the U.S people
would actually line with like wallpaper
swastikas in the top of the rooms and
things like that I see in the loop in
Chicago I would see a lot of that stuff
but it would be the inversion of the
swastika and then or something and then
the symbol became this is uh I will also
add
check out the music video uh handlebars
you guys remember that song oh yeah ride
my bike with no handlebars and in the
music video the bad guys the
totalitarian regime that's massacring
the people in the video have the BLM
fist on their Shields as they bang The
Shield's attractions and then open fire
on the crowd of innocent people so it's
funny how we're talking about I don't
know 12 years ago popular culture 70
million it was a big song shows blm's
symbolism as the evil authoritarian
regime and in that amount of time we now
see they're flying those flags one of
these things that I kind I feel like you
were mentioning that people have and I
think people have gone crazy but the
last 20 years or whatever it's been kind
of nuts is this obsession with uh words
and symbols as if less about the meaning
but more about the word itself like if
the actual text is carved into a spot
whoever did that's gonna suffer for
making that that shape on there it's a
word you know but what is the intention
of the war or what was the meaning of
the word that like the context like
it's so it's so dangerous to be afraid
of a word or afraid of a symbol as
opposed to being afraid of maybe what
these people are because someone if they
really want to hurt you they're not
going to say bad words they're going to
be very kind and very trusting that's
how you do it you know and you're going
to use perfectly clear PC I can tell you
why this happens uh it was actually
Congressman Massey who said it uh around
right after January 6 and they were
taking the military and they were they
were having military everywhere and they
had the fences put up everywhere to
protect the the White House and they
were having the military sleep in or the
National Guard sleep in the parking
garages and sleep in the just just
having every all this chaos everywhere
that made it look like a war zone and
Congressman Massey said this is what
this is what they do because they know
images are going to stay with you longer
than anything else so they are gonna
show you images and that's what you're
gonna remember so we we see these images
we should jump to this big breaking news
going on right now and we've got lots to
break down in the context of this the
post millennial reports Twitter's vice
president of trust and safety Ella Irwin
reportedly leaves the company amid daily
wired tobacco so this is huge head of
Twitter trust and safeties report
reportedly has resigned a report from
Forbes stated that she's no longer in
the top uh in the Twitter's internal
slack Reuters reporter Sheila dang said
that Irwin's resignation was confirmed
now this is a big story what's going on
all right let's let's get through this
Tim guest.com reporting mistake Elon
Musk says what is a woman can stream on
Twitter it's definitely allowed what do
we got here that's uh we have Zero Hedge
reporting on the rumor just before the
show started that she may have left the
company we've got uh film lad this one's
Big Jeremy boring says in a Twitter
space that the Twitter people who
canceled daily wires what is a woman
said Elon Musk was in the room and
approved the cancellation
as of right now
the visibility on Matt Walsh's tweet is
still limited restricted and my
understanding is that what is a woman
which was posted by the daily wire is
still being restricted by Twitter so the
story is the daily wire
planned in coordination with Twitter a
special event page to publish the
documentary what is a woman
at the last minute they were told that
they would not be allowed to run an
event page and that if they post the
documentary it would be labeled hate
speech Unlimited
so Matt Walsh posted the two clips in
question that they demanded be censored
and sure enough those tweets were
restricted and were limited Elon Musk
has come out and said that it's all a
mistake and of course it's allowed but
as of right now what I'm seeing on
Twitter they're still being heavily
limited and if the report is true Jeremy
boring saying that the Twitter people
tell him you know there's a lot a lot a
lot of uh uh hearsay there
some some is going on so the question is
is Elon Musk being forthright when it
comes to this issue and I'm leaning
towards no I like Elon I think he's
doing great work with SpaceX I can say
it a million times but when he tweeted
this was a big mistake and it's being
fixed and it's still not being fixed I
don't necessarily trust Elon Musk now
I'm not saying I don't trust him just
because someone claimed he was in the
room when when daily wire was confirmed
to be banned restricted doesn't mean he
actually was and the fact that the VP of
trust and safety is has resigned I
wonder if what's really happening is
that Elon Musk went in there and said
hey I I don't even know if he's in SF
right now because he was just in China
or something yes he might have been like
what's going on and why are you doing
this and maybe they were like if you
don't block this I quit and then he
probably said then quit and she said
fine so in order for Elon to get in like
I'll just put it this way
I still will get beyond the benefit of
that because he had no reason to tweet
in support of the daily wire when he did
but Ian miles strong was like it must
suck to be Elon you know you think
everything's going fine you wake up and
everything's on fire and I'm like not
only that but Elon isn't the one who's
doing all of this so all of a sudden
everyone on Twitter is screaming Elon
you've betrayed us and he's like in a
meeting and he comes I was like what's
happening like dude I'm not even here
right now let me take care of it it's
been on only a couple of hours now This
Woman's resigning it sounds like this
resignation shows Elon is taking heavy
action to rectify the problem
okay when I lost my page uh it was like
a month ago or whatever I woke up and I
couldn't log on to Twitter okay reached
out to Tim Tim put something out he's
like Elon Josie can't log on to Twitter
and elon's like oh I'm fixing it he
responded right that was weird yeah
um Ella directly got me my Twitter
account back really directly yep she
directly worked with me to get it back
why so this is so this is important
because your original Twitter account
was mysteriously shut down for no reason
no reason yep for a year and a half yep
but it was right before you made some
prediction or something right it was uh
right after I predicted that Joe Biden
Kamala Harris it was 20 right yeah yeah
so what was that I you tweeted that it
was gonna be Biden Harris yes so I
tweeted that in 20 June January 2019 I
tweeted that it was going to be Biden
Harris it's my pin tweet on my page you
can see it I said it's going to be Biden
Harris this is what it's going to be and
I said that January 2019 and then on the
day of the inauguration I I put it up
there and I said it's gonna this you
know I predicted this has happened and
like within within 10 days my page was
gone just gone I couldn't log in I was
permanently suspended no reason no idea
why it lasted for a year and a half then
Elon Musk on April 26th of last last
year said I'm gonna buy Twitter the next
day I got my account back then recently
you were locked mysterious again and it
was the same exact thing what happened
before but it wasn't like a normal
Banning no it was like I just couldn't
like your pages is gone Paige blanked
out I could there was nothing I couldn't
get into it it was just gone they didn't
know so what is that though with with
what you're saying there this see the
Ella Irwin this surprises me because
she's been pretty good about a lot of
stuff it's the new CEO that I thought
was gonna go so so yeah oh so maybe her
resignation is due to the new CEO it'll
get along it could be something like
that it could be that she resigned
because the people under her did this
and she didn't boss them correctly I'm
not sure I don't she just seemed really
good so that's why yeah if she was doing
if she was doing right yep by the users
and as to what Elon wanted and it was
underlings who acted up I'd imagine she
would not resign she would come out and
tweet and be like employees here are
upset and we're telling them no I bet
this is the new CEO
interesting and because I got because
then when she's like elon's yelling at
me I'm not doing this new CEO goes I'm
the CEO and I'm telling you to do it she
was I quit I'm done oh that's
interesting has the new CEO taken
taken like he maybe he put her in charge
when he was in China Linda yakarina yeah
yeah if he's not in the country right
now and she's running the company this
is what's going on that's very
interesting that it could have been what
she did immediately like having the
power to do that I mean Twitter's been
slow to change some of the stuff so I
wouldn't be surprised that there's you
know some people at the lower levels
that are still manipulating some of this
stuff like I was I was
censored from Twitter back in December
for saying that gender dysphoria is a
mental illness and I was locked out of
my account and and so but I don't know
if that's been fixed because I still
self-censor myself from saying that
because I don't know if it's going to
lock my account again you know check
that check this out so this is the daily
wires tweet they say it's the movie they
really don't want you to see what is a
woman watch the explosive documentary
starring Matt Walsh blog free on Twitter
for 24 hours and I'm gonna click this uh
just right here we got this little
retweet button it's our little retreat
but I'm gonna click that retweet button
why can't you retweet this we try to
keep Twitter a place for healthy
conversations so we've disabled most of
the ways to engage with this tweet
wow all in the name of being healthy
that tweet is so healthy like I feel
stronger already but yeah this this
still doesn't make any sense because
Elon bought Twitter because the Babylon
B right Sparks very much by The Babylon
B misgendering somebody and they're
saying the two scenes were because they
were misgendering
absolutely no sense I believe I have
Elon I just want to highlight this real
quick Jeremy boring has quote tweeted
the daily wire saying please share this
in case Twitter indeed throttles it I
have I've retweeted his quote tweet
which allows you to carry to share the
the documentary so I think what is woman
is a very good documentary and I'll tell
you why one of the scenes in question
that was limited Matt Walsh is actually
arguing from the perspective of trans
activists to the shop owner he's doing a
good job as an interviewer the
interviewer says here's how I feel about
trans people and then Matt Walsh says
but you don't you're not a scientist
like what how do you know and that he's
actually taking the points to get his
his response in reaction to it he's not
just approaching this like we already
have our our minds made up and working
he actually says like hey tell me what
you think I thought that was uh very
respectable I think the documentary was
very well done I've seen it twice now
um and what I really like about it
though is Matt didn't put his biases
into it I mean it is it's a bias it's
shaping a narrative into One Direction
but what he does is he goes into these
interviews and just lets the like the
trans activists just talk and they show
you who they are and so he didn't have
to like guide them in any direction and
what Tim's saying is correct and it's
interesting because I actually was um
last fall I was doing an event down in
Richmond I gotta interrupt sorry Elon
just tweeted we're updating the system
tomorrow so that those who follow real
daily wire yes
yep got it so
um I was doing an event last year in
Richmond
with no left turn education and
Eventbrite removed that event because we
were doing a screening of what is a
woman followed by a panel discussion
with me a doctor
um another human rights Advocate and
like so we were having a discussion
about it and it was still Eventbrite
took the event down that's the second
time or that's the first time out of two
that they've done that to me too people
are pointing out that Elon was in
Shanghai so he likely was not in the
room that doesn't make sense and the new
CEO isn't starting for a month or so so
I'm wondering what's happening but take
a look at this elon's basically saying
confirmed censorship on gender issues
Robbie Starbucks tweets despite Elon
Musk promising the real daily wire film
but his woman by Matt Walsh wouldn't be
censored it seems someone at Twitter
staff chose to censor it anyways less
than 20 minutes after it was posted you
can't even comment whoever did this
should be fired Elon says we're updating
the system tomorrow so that those who
follow real daily wire will see this in
their feed but it won't be amended to
non-followers nor will any advertising
be associated with it guess what that's
Elon Musk saying we will Shadow ban your
content
do you think this has this has something
to do with the uh the he just pulled out
of the EU agreement which is about to go
into effect next year that's going to
force companies to censor a speech or
not do business in that country I think
you know what I think it is I think Elon
sees Twitter
he sees the Babylon bee getting censored
he's like okay this is messed up he
genuinely is like I'm gonna buy Twitter
I think he has legitimate use for it
with ax that's why it's merged with X I
think he wants this for his One-Stop
Shop app it makes sense to buy ad
payment processing and video and stuff
and he genuinely thought he could have
free speech until the powers that be
from the international uh political
leaders came to him and we saw this with
turkey he said he didn't have a choice
with turkey ban some accounts or the
whole app gets banned and then One By
One The Dominoes fall and Elon Musk is
being pushed in the same direction as
Jack Dorsey I don't think he understood
the experiences of Jack Dorsey and why
Jack went this route and now Twitter is
going to end up being the exact same
thing that it was yeah dude Elon you
cannot control the One Ring man you need
free speech you need to free the
software code because you cannot control
this I explained what was going on and
Elon said exactly when when because
people were asking me about the EU
agreement I'm gonna find that and read
it so everybody knows exactly what's
going on according to Eli what is it
they're going to ban it in Europe or
something so yeah I'm pulling it up too
I wrote an article about this on human
events last week the EU disinformation
agency says Twitter has a legal
obligation to comply with oversight
program after Elon Musk pulls out so it
was a previously a
um it was a volunteer censorship program
essentially but the EU is
um so who is this this is
Terry Bratton the European the Europe's
commissions for internal markets the
voluntary code is basically going to be
put into effect with the DSA what's the
DSA
well I don't know but I can tell you
that uh I'm gonna refresh this from Matt
Walsh I'm pretty sure the digital
service act so they're implementing the
digital Service Act and they're gonna
basically Force companies to censor hate
speech yeah this unelected body of
European socialists yeah You're Not
Elected by me you have no swear over
what I do and say on on this Earth my
man this is crazy I can't retweet Matt
Walsh I wonder if I can just copy
and then uh manually do it right let's
see what happens if I try and do it this
way
so what's going on okay so
um somebody had asked this is my in my
Rea my conversation with Elon says the
EU is demanding Twitter censor by August
is he right or wrong to do it and I said
this is a good question and I don't
believe a lot of people understand how
deep this goes so I'm going to break it
down here countries without a Bill of
Rights to protect citizens from their
governments are threatening total bans
of Twitter if they're in their countries
if censorship orders are not complied
with many have enshrined hate speech
into law and have also created stringent
guidelines for social media operating in
their country so Elon Musk has two
options one limiting some material will
allow citizens in these despotic
countries to access Twitter minus some
censored material or two he will limit
no material which means these citizens
will have zero access to any and all
Twitter material in these countries so
ironically that's a total ban of Twitter
this is the exact same thing that
happened to Jack Dorsey yes and Elon
Musk is reacting in the exact same way
yep so he's com he's complying yep in
January musk had a meeting with Brenton
and said good meeting regarding the EU
DSA the goals of transparency
accountability and accurate information
are aligned with ours who said that in
January so this is just him moving that
needle forward I can't stand that word
accountability I'm so tired of these I'm
sorry interrupt what are you saying no
no I was going to agree with that oh
transparency accountability safety trust
get your word what do these words mean
it's another example
using letters like a cudgel but what's
the meaning behind it I mean diversity
Equity yeah it means I want to control
you is but that's not trust that's not
transparency show me the code of your
software
we're we're all Pavlov's dog and they
ring this Bell with any of these words
and that just means trust your
government you know what they are
they're dog whistles to a particular
ideology
we all know very well
unfortunately Bella Irwin's got that as
the first word in her Twitter bio trust
advocate well they they yeah it's
meaning trust it's cult it is it is a
weird cult that use they they use
emotional manipulation to indoctrinate
and control and this is what I'm talking
about with seeing people like uh
military cadets marching in a parade
with pride Flags like it is ideological
capture of a country it is it the
ideological symbol of this country
should be the American flag yes it is
being subverted Now by a cult yeah and
you know what it is I can't tell you how
many people I talk to who are like leave
me out of it yep and I'm like okay well
then when they show up at your doorstep
yeah you need technology we're never
going to get rid of the American flags
everything they says they it's the iron
level projection but you already see
teachers in the classrooms get rid of
the American flag and put up the pride
flag instead that's because these These
are the activists and these are the
activists that are going to make the
policy and that's what's gonna happen
well it's not even the proud flag it's
the progress flag which that triangle
infiltrating on the rainbow yeah is very
symbolic you have an arrow just taking
over everything have you ever seen them
put the pride flag in a um yes it makes
a swastika yep yep
I think the only way to resist is a
technological resistance of
decentralized software social media that
can't be well it's encrypted at the very
least that can't be controlled by a
centralized service or isn't built for
centralized Services just like the
American Revolution in 1776 was a
technological Revolution they used boats
and cannons as their technology we don't
need to use weapons we can use social
media but we need to protect ourselves
and resist this economic torment this
this insane communist or socialist
attempt at controlling the Earth did you
guys see that uh Bud Light sponsored an
lgbtq event and a pride parade just
after after the show yes I'm
surprised they have but this is the
thing is a lot of people are waking up
to is all this stuff has been going on
for years it was the Mulvaney effect
pushed it into the mainstream like Bud
Light Coors Light all these companies
have always had like rainbow cans for
Pride events and all this other stuff
and it's never been an issue until this
year and now you're seeing it with all
these
all these organizations we talked about
there was a I wrote an article today it
was about PetSmart so PetSmart has dog
toys and all this stuff that's Pride
stuff which really I don't care if you
put a rainbow flag on a dog toy or
anything like that you wanted you're a
dog owner you and you're gay or lesbian
or or bi or whatever
I don't really care if they do that but
the hidden meaning behind it is then
they also said that they gave two
hundred thousand dollars to glisten what
is glisten I've been hearing about it
they are an organization that basically
promote teachers keeping secrets from
parents in school so they that's like
their biggest advocacy is working with
governments to ensure that that's
happening so that you know children have
autonomy in classrooms from parents and
so teachers can keep those secrets and
that's what they're pushing so they're
pushing the gender ideology onto onto
school so when you're supporting
somebody like something like PetSmart
Kohl's Target who have been donating
Millions to this com to this
organization that's what you're
supporting when I pulled the story from
Yahoo news it's a story originally from
The Advocate Bud Light pledges two
hundred thousand dollars to support
lgbtq plus business owners of color they
also recently sponsored a pride parade
right if a company is seeing a 30 drop
off in sales has fallen from the number
one spot to number two has seen a stock
drop off of 27 billion dollars that's
billion with a B
and then they double down that's not a
business I'll tell you why that's not a
business because a business is trying to
produce a service or product and sell it
to people Bud Light is an advocacy
Institution
I I think two two important things I
think America uh American first legal
I believe it is I'm not entirely sure uh
someone is saying if you were a
shareholder contact us this looks like a
very serious violation of their
fiduciary duties to their shareholders
you may have a legal case I will also
say
well there's two there's one other thing
I want to add to this but the first is
this this is this company in my opinion
is probably going to collapse into a
certain degree if they keep doing this
you can't like they're really crossing
their fingers that Bud Light as beer
will do better than like they like they
don't need it to be a company anymore it
is now be they're hoping that it is a
solidified entrenched institution that
can never be dismantled too big to fail
then they can wear it like a skin suit
and use the money you buy for beer to
support a cult
think about that Bud Light is not a
business it is funneling your money into
a cult despite knowing it is destroying
their business it's because they don't
care when the brain slug latches onto
your skull does the brain slug care
whether you live or die that's obviously
brain slugs aren't real my point is
whatever strange creature has gripped
Bud Light it doesn't care if it if it
sucks the the innards out until it
Withers into a husk and collapses
because it is extracting the resources
from this once Great American
Institution
they know they're collapsing their
shareholders know it's collapsing Bud
Light does not care yes and I know why
there's a name for that slug it's called
CEI it's C HRC is that slug that's using
CEI because Bud Light just lost their
perfect CEI score which feeds into their
Dei score like last week their ESG score
I gotta I have a viral tweet about it
actually it's got a 35 000 likes on it
so I'm just going to read that it's
titled why is everything gay buckle up
because we're going down the gay Rabbit
Hole the CEI is the corporate the
corporate equality index
it is a woke credit score that judges
companies based on how many woke issues
they're posting and then to get ahead of
it I said well what is woke because
that's always the question well you guys
don't even know what that means it's
like yeah it's the it's a presence we
all know what it means but it says the
words co-opted from the black community
by gender activists and it's been
infected with this cultural War it's
been affected with neo-marxism that's
what it is so who made it up and who
gives the score so from my understanding
it's the Human Rights Campaign HRC sends
lobbyists to these countries and it
gives them a list of these demands and
if they do not comply with these demands
then the woke investors put pressure on
the boards activists are mobilized
advertising campaigns are shut down they
lose their funding they lose their
investors they they get threats so
anyone who continues to do business with
them these people they get penalized as
well anybody who does business so so
who's funding the HRC there's a lot of
different ones and two of them are um
through George Soros companies the first
one is the open Society foundation and
the other one is like the George Soros
Foundation or something and this is
something you can vet you can look it up
right now so who runs the open Society
Foundation then I wrote uh oh definitely
don't Google that because we're not
allowed to talk about that guy he's the
one we shall not talk of
uh so essentially if you don't if you
don't get a good score the lizard god
king of the world doesn't let your
business exist
um so this fake score is everywhere it's
controlling everything it's it's
coercion and this is the despotic rot
that is light doesn't care about their
business so I there there's there's
nothing
Bud Light doesn't care about making
money yes
so so what so what is happening now is
it's demoralization it's part of that
denationalization thing that I was
talking about earlier this is the
demoralization process so what they do
they they they take an American
institution like Bud Light like Target
like Walmart and they like Tim had said
they infect it with this brain slug now
the idea is that people are just going
to accept that that's what they want you
to believe like no we're just going to
do this this is the way forward we're
going to accept that but that's not the
truth as you can tell by the stocks
dropping and how much money they're
losing people aren't just accepting that
so that means that it it it's uh an
American institution is going to fail a
prestigious American institution going
to fail before our eyes and it's going
to demoralize the country and that's
that's what it is it's Belgian now it's
owned by in the ABN Bev which is a
Belgian company so they essentially sold
out I'm trying to find out when
Budweiser sold out to the belgians
um I can't find a year but it's not an
American company anymore it has the red
white and blue uh Allah has the red and
white logo and then Bud Light as the
blue and white it's an establishment
it's at every fourth of July picnic you
know it's it's Memorial Day it's an
American institution like an American
icon that are actually just they're just
gonna take it down belgians are using
I'm not blaming all Belgian people but
this Belgian company is using it to to
trick people into giving them money to
impact and invest on whatever they want
but they're letting the Budweiser brand
fall apart right now they don't care
you're right they don't care because
it's a b in bed it's worth probably a
thousand times what Budweiser itself is
worth or something I don't know what the
exact numbers are but it's just a drop
in the bucket of their of their total
brand I think people need to understand
it the the Constitution is meaningless
to a culture that does not care for the
Constitution yes it can say whatever it
wants it can say all of these really
great things and if the people behind
what's happening with Bud Light and
young people when they get older if they
are the dominant cultural Force you will
have soldiers in your homes you won't
have guns you won't have speech you
won't have a right to a trial you'll go
to a trial and they'll say man you're
guilty because we said so look at look
at Donald Trump being found criminally
liable of a 30 30 year old insane insane
story about how he went to a clothing
store and had sex with a woman and then
she was like oh he found we found the
one dressing room that was open and then
he had his way with me or whatever and
it's just there's no evidence there's
there's no logic to it Trump at the peak
of his Fame walking with no security
into a heavily populated department
store and nobody notices or says
anything no one comes up to him and then
he finds an empty room like this story
is completely insane but they still said
yep confirmed you like we are we are
inching towards this point
look at the January 6 defendants there's
a guy who's on video who's talking to
the cops
smiling and nodding his head and then
ushering people out of the building a
proud boy he got 12 years in federal
prison even though he was helping the
police they don't care they will lie
then you will be like well I'll I'll go
to trial and then the jurors are all
going to be sitting there waving their
cult flags and they're gonna be like we
don't care what the Constitution says we
won we will lock you up and the cops
will come to your house and say I have a
First Amendment right to speak and
they'll be like none of that matters
anymore and then they'll crack you the
trunch and throw in the van yeah the
problem with the U.S Constitution is
it's not adapted to the age of the
Internet it's it's still reliant on
before no that has nothing to do with
what I'm talking it totally does because
mob mentality can spark overnight now
with the internet and that the
constitution can't stop it and no
Constitution can stop but literally
nothing but something that prevents at
least prevents people from
um controlling social media can allow us
to stop it but if we can't stop social
media from muting our conversations then
no one can stop it so we need free
speech in that we need these systems to
be free and open so that we can organize
as the Constitution intended for us I I
agree to a certain
I I agree I agree to a certain degree
but the issue is
when the left started encroaching and
enforcing these things people on the
right said I'm so scared please just
leave me alone and they they did they
did nothing very few people I mean a lot
of people did don't get me wrong Trump
obviously rose up he got elected
but I can't tell you how many look Bud
Light they only lost 30 of their sales
there are still people who will drink
Bud Light or other a b inbev products
there are still people on the right who
who aren't going to do anything and
they're going to be like I'd rather just
keep my head down and not say a word
and so long as so it look the problem is
not that evil exists it's that good man
do nothing yeah yeah I think people are
waiting for someone else to fix the
Constitution right now and I like I'm
open to Rapid adaptation but I'm also
very concerned about rapid adaptation I
don't want anybody in I I don't want to
see another Amendment added by this
Congress like
even I'd even be worried about
um the Article 5 States uh convention
like at this point I just I don't trust
anybody there's so many Communists
infiltrated into the government that if
they added another amendment God knows
God knows what it would do I I just I
believe the way forward is the tenth
amendment I believe that the way forward
is like you know like the courts that
are corrupt those those courts are in
New York those courts are in DC you know
they that's there's a Stranglehold there
on these corrupt courts I worry about
what happened to Donald Trump because
they could they could do the stick
Justice Kavanaugh now they could make
him guilty Bud Light needs to collapse
it's a big ask but Bud Light needs to
collapse completely to the point of it
being a non-existent product
so that a message is sent that there is
a red line that we will not cross
otherwise they can capture institutions
and then gut them strip the resources
and people keep buying it and they will
just use it like a skin suit yep I was
going to ask you do you think that there
will come a point where
but Anheuser-Busch is realizing that bud
light's just draining everything and to
get rid of this they just cut Bud Light
loose close the brand and then just move
on with something else they'll still
produce Bud Light but under a different
name not not by choice yeah once it's uh
dead it's it's dead yeah if people don't
buy it at all and so we're hearing more
and more and more that people are not
buying it sales are down 29.5 that that
is insanely massive that may be getting
to the point where it's not no longer
profitable to produce well it and it's
no longer profit well and then it will
take a turn when you know BlackRock and
Vanguard don't have enough money to
support these industries so I'll I don't
know like Anheuser-Busch obviously Bud
Light is the biggest well then not
anymore they're not number one Modelo is
not number one in the United States
which is huge great but let me tell you
I love that we we we're making this
coffee over at caspro and it is very
very difficult we've invested a quarter
million dollars to start we actually
started with a little bit less and then
we keep having to put more money in when
we sell a bag of coffee we do make a
profit but then we have to reorder that
bag and we have to recycle the profits
because we sold out so quickly we have
to order more coffee the next time which
consumes all the profits plus more
I would love to get to the point where
we could sell cans of cold brew all over
the country the issue is that producing
canned liquids you need to order a lot
of it you know we had Seth weather this
year he was saying no you couldn't do it
less you could do it cheaper
every company we've talked to about
production distribution sourcing and all
that stuff they've basically said it'll
come out to about five bucks for a can
and I'm like that's crazy like that's a
lot and I understand you go to the gas
station it might be like 3.99 for a can
of cold brew as it is and the reason
they get the like Star Wars look at that
cost down is because they'll make 50
million cans or maybe not 50 but like 10
million cans and then they if they make
10 cents per can they're going to make
enough profit for it to work for them
but for us we cannot produce enough of
this to to uh get the price down that
low you make a million cans and you make
a dollar per can you get a million
dollars profit you can reinvest for us
we can do a few thousand cans which
means in order to reinvest we need
larger margins so we have to sell it for
more if Bud Light sales drop 30 percent
people need to understand this it
doesn't mean that they're going to be
like oh well we're still getting you
know if we sold 100 cans you know per
day now we're selling 70. that might be
their margin of profit it might now go
to the point where
if they were making a dollar per per can
of Bud Light losing thirty dollars off
each shipment might now mean the profit
is only five dollars or none they needed
those 30 cans to generate the percentage
the profit margin yeah
volume matters the more you sell your
you'll make less profit in the long run
but you make enough profit to support
the employees support the business if
Bud Light drops down to like 50 they're
gonna have to cut production they're
gonna have to fire staff and they're
probably already getting to that point
and they're probably already at the
point where they're now subsidizing Bud
Light because not only are they not
selling the stuff
they have to get rid of the old stuff
which costs money to dispose of yeah so
that's called the economies of scale
what you're talking about and so when
you produce this stuff and most of these
companies they forecast for entire year
so they know exactly how much they're
going to order at each quarter of each
year and so for yeah they're they're
sitting here with all this stock on hand
going what are we going to do now a lot
of these companies moved into a
just-in-time production systems but it's
really hard when you're working with you
know in massive scales to just go full
just in time and then what you're
talking about with especially with Bud
Light because it's a perishable item
they can't just send it to like a
consignment shop like at the end of each
season clothing Source sort of send that
stuff to a consignment shop so that they
can just sell it off you know like TJ
Maxx and stuff like that but like
they're giving it away because it costs
more in logistics costs to send it back
than it does to give it away my back my
background before I started doing this
was in logistics so now it's not in my
area let's let's go to the local level
John Rich you know me you love them good
dude said that they replaced Bud Light
simply because it wasn't moving it he he
didn't even frame it like we're
boycotting he was like look nobody
bought it so we need to get something
else out there that we're going to sell
because we need to make money
if you are a bar and I'm sure a lot of
people who watch are work at bars or
manage bars or own bars you know that if
you order x amount of Bud Light but only
sell 70 of what you ordered you're going
to reduce your purchase substantially or
just not buy it outright because you
don't want waste not only that but
considering it's getting worse and worse
for Bud Light many and many many bars or
whatever might just be like I don't want
to buy it at all because even if we cut
our sales down to 50 of what our normal
order was if tomorrow it gets worse
we're sitting on more dead product
nobody cares about Yingling people like
Yingling nobody cares about cores or
Miller just buy that instead because I
tell you this someone's going to come in
and then go I'll take a Bud Light and
you'll go uh we got course they'll go
okay yeah plain and simple so why take
the risk I think we are watching an epic
collapse of Bud Light and I don't know
how far it'll go
they may have to raise the price but how
is that going to help them when they're
already giving the beer away for free I
could see them repackaging the actual
liquid with a different brand yep they
would have to get a re-certified I think
because you can't I don't know if you
can sell the same product under a
different name you'd have to go through
that and then if people find out that
it's Bud Light repackaged they're gonna
boycott it again so it's a risk this is
what I've always I've always thought
about I've always been kind of surprised
at some of these major institutions like
but Anheuser-Busch and all these like
even Target and all these other stores
Nike all this stuff like that they've
done so well as smaller brands have
popped up I mean especially with beer
beer there's there's a Craft brewery on
every corner in America now so I'm
surprised that they've even been able to
hold out this long because of the
competitions there I wonder if they got
bought by inbev in 2008 that was the uh
the Belgian company and I wonder if
they've been running it at like margins
of like one cent per can the whole time
oh yeah it's probably microscopic just
keep brand awareness it's just a brand
awareness product they're not even maybe
they're even running at a loss I don't
know so so at that point it becomes a
financial institution instead of a
production company
I I I would be willing to bet that their
profit per can is ridiculously low a
couple cents if that it could even be
fractions of pennies like we sell a
million cans we make a hundred grand
well they make it up somewhere too
because even like most people don't know
like McDonald's at one point they would
make 70 of their profit on their
breakfast menu and they would sell fries
and drinks at a loss and actually a lot
of stuff they would sell at a loss
because they were making it actually no
they would they would sell their
hamburgers at a loss because the drinks
made up for the loss you get people
cheap Bud Light at a loss then they
become alcoholics and then they'll buy
your other stuff
so check this out uh I just Google
searched what is what is the
Anheuser-Busch profit margin and it's
12.78 percent
so if they're fixed cost is
like a million bucks whatever just
random number yeah and they lose 30 of
sales
they lose 30 of their profit that may
barely cover their fixed costs or I'll
give you another example that's much
easier to understand
this is what happened in Detroit
you have a hypothetical million people
live in Detroit they say we're going to
build a water system that will cost
everyone uh 100 bucks per month and
everyone goes oh okay 100 bucks a month
is really expensive but we're going to
get public excess water so now your
water bill for your house is 100. it
might it's probably it's probably way
less you know at the time it was
probably like 20 bucks then half the
population leaves
the water system still has to be
maintained by the exact same people
their salaries stay the same
but only half the people are paying the
the taxes now and the bills what happens
the cost of water doubles
then 250 000 people leave those who
remain now have quadrupled their bills
this is what happened and that's why uh
yeah what happened with Flint is that
they were like our water costs are so
incredibly High we're gonna use Flint
River water instead because it'll be
cheaper and then they had legionnaires
and a bunch of other nasty stuff in
their water and chemicals or whatever
lead that's from the pipes wow but so
the point is if Bud Light says we have a
fixed operating cost of a million
dollars and for every can we sell we get
you know a penny
we need to make a million plus whatever
if the profit margins drop down to a
certain point but the fixed costs to
hire the people working the factory
remain the same they've got to raise the
cost of beer raising the cost of a
product that people are already not
buying then what's going to happen is
someone's going to walk into a store who
doesn't care and they're going to say uh
I'll take a 20 pack of I don't know
whatever you got Bud Light and they're
like that's uh 37 whoa what 37 I thought
it was 15.99 like well the modelo's
15.99 give me the Modelo they're going
to be like oh Bud Lights more expensive
now because less people are buying it so
they need to increase the margin so they
can cover their fixed costs they
actually wouldn't I mean they would be
able to they wouldn't do that because of
that because it's sitting right next to
Modelo yep and they got a business yeah
immediately so they'll have to figure
out another way the repackaging Scandal
is one way to do it maybe that's why
this they're trying to go they're
actually trying to lean back into the
LGBT community because that's the only
way that you can do it yeah they're
targeting if you target that community
and honestly of the population they're
like do college kids care that's where
most of their profit comes from probably
anyways because they're broke yeah
that's that's an ABC it's an
Anheuser-Busch brand what they could do
what what they could do this is what
this this is what they do in like um uh
the clothing that's really really lovely
right they pretty much they put a label
on it and they say this is worth more
money because it's uh it's Gucci you
know this is and so people see the label
and they're like oh so this could be
some sort of rebranding like what's
going to be more expensive but you know
they could uh start targeting it as like
a brunch beer oh or some way to Target
and maybe Budweiser gold but yes exactly
Budweiser got hit by like 12 as well wow
so and all of the Anheuser Brands got
hit what they might do is say we've got
fixed costs we've got to sell let's here
here look if they change Bud Light to
say like natural Plus or something they
then have to go to all the Distributors
and say carry this beer instead that is
an immense amount of work they've got to
get approval which wouldn't be too hard
for a massive company like
Anheuser-Busch but they've got to then
switch out all their contracts from Bud
to the new brand if they want to save it
yo if if we wake up one day in a few
months and Bud Light is done as a brand
that would be one of the most the most
trip a tremendous culture War victory
yeah it wouldn't be against the world
cult I think in a b in general is in
trouble I mean did you see
um Harley-Davidson threw them a Lifeline
last week and they changed the cans of
Budweiser to try to you know Drive some
Revenue I think that would only drive
Harley-Davidson down yep I'm surprised
they did it actually I wonder what uh
Harley Davidson stock is at I bet it's
fine to be completely honest again I
think a lot of people are still just
looking at it as oh yeah
stable oh wait no it's down two percent
so maybe they did oh wait when when was
that campaign it was last week right it
was was it this last weekend I feel like
it was yes
let's make sure we get the the day
because I might have something to show
you it could have something to do with
their with their CEI too like oh we're
we're gonna work with this company
that's you know was it Friday
it might have been all right well I'll
just pull this up because uh since
Friday they've actually dipped 2.34
percent oh yeah so they there there's a
that looks like I bet you right there's
a visual problem I'm just gonna use some
logic here and I'm gonna say that that
is when the campaign happened yeah but
it's not apocalyptic because all they
did was do a partnership can and as of
today it's up like point two percent
after hours is 0.2 percent but since
last Friday they uh okay so Friday then
Tuesday the 30th it was at 33 it's
dropped 2.34 percent
so it's actually it's low was down uh
was like almost two three dollars
yeah their Bud light's way down I want
to screenshot it and put like one of
those progress Flags like right where it
drops and then be like boom so we put it
out on the 27th so we put the article on
the 27th so yeah it would have been
Friday Thursday or Friday so when people
are reading the new there it is boom
yeah that Tuesday and that was uh
yeah dang it Tuesdays when the drop this
was this was app and it makes sense
because Monday was Memorial day yeah was
that no stock trading on Memorial Day I
I think so it goes Friday to Tuesday so
it drops right no that's crazy right
when people are back from the from the
holiday it's the queer Theory effect
boys and girls wow I I call it I call it
the Bud Light effect I'm all about
impact investment uh if you do it right
this is just like a battle of wills
because like Tim what you did with the
uh Times Square uh Banner the Times
Square Billboards that was impact
investment that wasn't didn't make the
company any money necessarily off the
top it just brought brand awareness to
what you want to be but that's not
impact investment it's a form of it it's
it but no it's just you're right it's
advertising it's not technically if if
we put investment if we put up an ad
that said something like you know woke
is bad yeah that's an impact investment
yeah yeah yeah you're right we just put
a Billboards I was like watch the show
it's great but even that like
uh using your own personal money or your
company's money to promote things you
like I mean that seems righteous on its
heel it's just a matter of if you like
psycho stuff then
you know maybe do you think should it be
illegal for business owners to spend
their businesses money I don't think so
I mean I think it should be I think it
should be illegal for places like HRC to
create a woke credit score that people
have to abide by if they want to compete
who's giving age no no so again that's
that's all based off BlackRock and
Vanguard who's who's running the the
ESPN scores because that feeds into the
ESG score what is this look at this
shelf yeah so Friday it's here
Tuesday because of the holiday weekend
it dropped two bucks right away five
percent down in five days it's funny
they didn't sell as much as they thought
they would on Monday for the holiday
apparently look at this it's so bad at
the start of the year they were at 60
bucks and now they're at 53. the power
of the people like it's going to keep
going down like I can't imagine anyone
look when Bud Light comes out
so you've got the summer months coming
up you've got great reports and then
March March 31st is the day before Dylan
Mulvaney there was a quick sell I
remember when it went down and here's
what I think I think people saw it go
down and went boycotts never work I'm
gonna buy the dip so it goes back up a
little bit and then it didn't stop and
now the people who are holding it are
like okay we can't hold on to this we
got to sell it there's literally no sane
reason to hold on to a stock that is
doubling down on on why it's crashing
which is
perhaps the woke don't care that they
will destroy this Company's stock
because Anheuser-Busch stock is not just
Bud Light Bud Light is one product of
hundreds
but this company is has said we we know
you're angry this what did the CSA we
didn't want to be involved in a
conversation that was divisive let's
give hundreds of thousands of more
dollars to more of these organizations
they know they are ripping their country
to shreds so if you're someone's still
holding the stock
that's the definition of insanity the
internet definition of insanity they are
holding their hand to a to a glass top
stove and going like yeah but give it a
it'll stop burning in a second that's
the sunk cost fallacy well I mean look
at the top of this chart if you if you
were an investor and you paid attention
to a show like this and you went what's
this there's a there's a controversy
with Bud Light I'm gonna sell all my
stock it's peaked it's really high and
I'm gonna buy a company that does beer
that's not controversial and you
invested in say Coors you are up 20 yeah
or something like that if you said and
this will all blow over you are down
10.84 this year and from the peak you're
down way more I think 15 it's probably
more than 15 to be honest because that's
just the past month and we're looking at
two months so you're down from 66 to 53.
yeah and that in that Gap it has to do
with the initial sell-off happened I
think a lot of people thought that you
know there's going to be a pump of you
know ESG money into this into it to get
them past the controversy but the
controversy never passed and so now
you're seeing the effect of the boycott
actually taking taking place because now
it's like hey this isn't going away we
don't have enough money to save this
stock and so that's the difference
between like sales and profit in
companies and financial institutions of
money of companies because that's where
the stock market and companies don't
necessarily match up with you know a
stock price is not indicative of profits
necessarily
I imagine that they were shutter they
were feeling the shake of pain maybe
there was an influx of ESG money for
this first month but that they were they
were realizing for the first month what
they're gonna have to cut like
everything is is is falling now so and
then you don't start to see it you know
they tried their best to kind of mask it
with rebuys of stock and stuff in the
past six months Target is down 20 in the
past six months Walmart is down 3.79 so
something's interesting because you
brought something up that's really
interesting you said look at this first
dip and then it's like oh but then they
said boycotts don't work yep so that's
interesting because it does do Target do
they have they don't okay so that came
afterwards so I wonder if they're like
okay boycotts work now yeah exactly so
you take a look at this you look at
Target and right around the time the
controversy started May 17th that from
160 all the way down to 130 30 bucks off
their share price and there was no dip
yeah ever so New York mag wrote this
article and they said when I heard about
the Bud Light boycott I said it's not
going work it never works and then it
did and now people are scared like uh oh
why get there's there's no one here and
no one online can give me a legitimate
reason as to why you would intentionally
hold a stock facing a massive
controversy when you can with a swipe of
your phone sell the stock buy any other
company not controversial wait and then
buy it back later on if you really
wanted to doesn't make sense nothing it
doesn't make sense at all so I can only
imagine there there are people who are
holding on to the stock uh for a b and
both who don't really pay attention and
have a diverse portfolio in their life
you know stocks go up and down I'm gonna
but I wouldn't be surprised if
seeing it's a really great point you
made that Target doesn't have the rebuy
people buying the dip because people are
like nope I'm getting out of this
exactly I think people are waking up and
the fact that the stock star is
incredible I wouldn't be surprised if
come next week ab and Bev is in the 40s
and then welcome it imagine being down
30 some odd percent on on the stock that
you bought and still thinking that you
can hold it's like it's like a gambler's
fallacy almost I think you're right
though as most people when they put
their stuff in like mutual funds and and
all that stuff they're not thinking
about that and their investor is doing
it so
why is my 401k yeah what's going on and
so you have to go look and see what your
mutual funds are invested in if they're
invested in Anheuser-Busch you might
want to go uh tell your
but that would also be possibly a
lawsuit against you know the financial
institution that's holding the mutual
fund because they're not completing
their fiduciary duty to get out of a bad
stock
I think there's there's serious lawsuit
potential yeah the the there are
safeguards in place for stockholders
and
the institutions may be captured Bud
Light a b and Bev may be captured by
woke Psychopaths but there is still a
mechanism to defend those from someone
it could really it could be really
simple it could be using Wellness to
intentionally destroy a company for some
reason and I wonder this
who has short has shorted but but suck
because when Bud here's what I think
when I'm when I see Bud Light say we're
going to sponsor more Pride events and
give more money I'm like okay
who at that company told a friend to bot
to short to buy put options because
they're like hey we lost 30 because of
this and then someone goes 30 30 of your
sales that's a lot of put up so yep so
this this boycott's huge so what do you
think in a week you could lose 10 if you
did it again it could be a 10 drop I'll
put a hundred grand in puts yeah and
then you do it again boom we get a 10
return I would be investigating that but
of course the doj is fairly woke they
probably won't but I'm willing to bet
someone somewhere
but put options on bud because you know
we were talking about this before we
were like man we read the news all day
every day why don't we invest in what we
talk about because we knew this was
happening before it happened and I was
like I don't know I think the Stock's
going to drop and it was it was fine
people were buying the dip I could have
bought a bunch of puts and be like oh
yeah I bought you know but I didn't I
don't do any of that stuff but I wonder
how many people watching probably did
how much money did they make yeah this
is I have a very important question is
the Paul Pelosi stock tracker back on
Twitter
because that is where all of our answers
lie my friends I think there is a woke
index okay yes that's uh so there's um
someone go check that and put it in the
super chats there had been a lot of
people have been pointing out that
companies that embrace wokeness are not
going to make money because they're
embracing ideology over meritocracy
so there have been people who have
targeted these companies for shortage to
short them because their life if they
outright publicly say they care more
about ideology over actually being a
company they're going to lose a ton of
money it's a GameStop but not because
it's not like they're not intentionally
tanking the stock
yeah interesting
um
I I was the same way I thought that this
was gonna just blow over but I think you
know it is the fact that Bud Light is
perishable it will have a bigger impact
because when the whole scandal with Alta
happened well one that was targeting
women who tend to be more forgiving on
these types of things but the stock
tanked for like a week and then it
skyrocketed and I thought Bud Light was
going to do the exact same thing when it
came to again like the vanguards and
stuff like that pumping money into it
but when it didn't you're absolutely
right I think you're a fool if you don't
get out of it now I absolutely love
having Sarah here to talk about
logistics everybody should go follow her
because I don't know I don't know
anything about logistics I am not giving
anybody advice or telling them what to
do with their stock because you know I
don't know I don't trade stocks
individually either so not I'm not very
good at it I do recommend you do find
Paul Pelosi's portfolio true
yeah so we're what's going on we got
more more tweets coming from uh Elon
Musk I'm getting a bunch of messages oh
yeah yeah I I am too
what's going on Elon said commenting and
deliberate sharing will be allowed
sensitive content just won't be pushed
to people unless they ask for it or a
friend sends it to them
interesting that's that's interesting
but why don't they I mean if if that's
the case I guess he's trying to keep
everybody happy but what they should
what he should do is they should put
they should push it like they normally
do every other tweet and then just put
the content warning label that you have
to click show that that covers your
bases Elon just tweeted a few minutes
ago I will be actively lobbying to
criminalize making severe irreversible
changes to Children below the age of
consent shame on those who Advocate this
it is utterly utterly contemptible very
weird goings-on right now yeah well he
was very what he talked about the
gendering he's like I personally will
gender you whatever you want just as a
term of respect but then when it comes
to to kids like he's like
you know you're all going down yeah
we're sure it's Elon Musk that's hard
line which was Elon Musk not Elon Musk
press
very likely
it's a Elon Musk yeah he's got a little
symbol next to it no that that whole
thing about children he is dead
seriously yeah yeah we gotta we gotta we
gotta jump to Super chats so uh we'll
start reading these uh smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends we're gonna
have a members only show so go to
timcast.com click join us and then we
will talk more and take your questions
from our take the questions from our
members
all right I'm not your buddy guy says am
I the a-hole for laughing at Biden
falling I mean look at what he did to
his kids to your country hell he sold
your country for personal wealth
oh man you're not the only one laughing
yeah that's tough man it really is
because he's a bad guy
but I I just I can't bring myself to do
it I am not the kind of person who
Revels in
something like that you know like if it
was backfiring if if he did something
and then the result of what he did
caused him harm I would be like well I
mean come on like you know you threw a
baseball at the wall it bounced back and
hit you it's it's it's funny it's like
you know sorry it happened but it's fine
being an old man and falling over I'm
just not about that yeah I feel like
we're all gonna get old I feel you know
really sorry for him and bad for him and
I mean I'm also a woman so I have more
empathy and emotions and I shouldn't be
voting so so this is well okay this
isn't this is an example because of my
emotions are like I feel so sorry for
him like I wanted to give him a hug and
I hate this man yeah I I think that
there's a difference too because I think
he went from being this bad guy his
whole career for a politician
which all politicians are pretty much
bad guys but I think there's a point now
where he is the victim he's the victim
of elder abuse and in a lot of ways he
is they're pushing him to do this I find
him ambitious and not incapable he's not
incapable but he's on his way to
incapability where he can't get out of
the bed I mean yeah parts of his brain
are still there the parts that want to
be doing this I can tell he wants to do
it but at a point people who love him
need to say you you shouldn't be doing
it what do you think 30 to 60
for what 35 I think is the age for
presidency so 35 is 65 yes 65 I mean the
age of retirement's a good age test grip
strength that's what I want to know yeah
30 to 65 retirement age yeah yeah I'd
say 365 35 65. Aaron asks says Twitter
doesn't surprise me I was banned from
Twitter for impersonating William
Shakespeare
[Music]
see I'm surprised about that that is
awesome
defiant blackouts as someone said there
was a child for him to sniff in that
direction he got ahead of himself
one other person Nigel says Twitter
doing this doesn't surprise me I was
banned for Jeff the left doesn't Patrick
Bateman
was that
uh Holden pointing out Twitter's
director of name or something trust and
safety just resigned crazy
Raymond g Stanley Jr says happy month
before Maga month it's American
greatness month in a short 30 days
friends we will be celebrating Maga
month the bestest month of all the best
months everyone says so 31 days of
barbecues family and beers not Bud Light
we don't like Bud Light so uh I'm really
excited for Maga month man
this is American greatness month
so we celebrate the American flag we put
the American flag everywhere and then on
Maga month you got to change all your
profile pictures to Little American flag
pictures I like the American greatness
month I am so done with pride even as
somebody who's in the LGBT community
because it's just so taken over it's
taken over by the leftist
um that want to destroy the country so
we don't need a month we have every
other day it seems so yeah there's no
need it and we don't need I mean
representation is everywhere so what are
we even celebrating or what are we
protesting you know what we need you
tweeted that right the Navy the Navy did
the meme or something oh probably that's
something it shows the fighter jets and
the drones with rainbows coming out of
them it's like okay when the military is
like our drone bombs are rainbows like
okay we get it I wanted the military is
gay what are people what are people
proud of this is all about being proud
is it just proud of who you are because
that's the original message for me me
being myself is not enough to have pride
I need to do something good with this
body yes and I do feel like a lot of
people would be deeply offended even if
you were proud of yourself yeah
I think it's like they're putting it in
their face they're like look it we're
gonna do this and God's Not Gonna flood
the Earth it's like it's almost like
here's our rainbow no one's flooding it
is now in your face yeah I think it's
funny the
um bring on the flood memes yeah it's
like a subreddit like yeah what is it
called Noah get the boat or something
like that yeah Noah and then it's like
get the boat and he's got lit and up
eyes and it's zoomed in on him
yeah well Sheamus I think said the most
brutal thing ever he said if God doesn't
Smite the United States he's owes Sodom
and Gomorrah an apology oh I know wow
bangers that's a quote that's out that's
a dark quote I don't know if that's
blasphemous
all right let's grab some more Super
chats what do we have over here
monkin training says he tripped on the
floor a couple people have pointed this
out that it looks like there is a bump
or something or a carpet or a big flame
some kind of sandbag but why would there
be a sandbag there was no sandbag unless
the sandbag was propping him up
initially instead of I've seen some
images I was uh tweeted some images that
show there's notes that's just flat okay
what is that black thing I don't know I
don't know if the issue even like
looking at that it's it's seems like
it's closer than it is it's really
difficult to tell from the video that's
interesting yeah Kevin Simmons says to
have a stream of content for the coffee
shop perhaps an aggregating software and
auto player as needed like an RSS feed
for video autoplay you have a plan for
that or does it need to be developed
it's actually not that difficult no we
would just curate a playlist of the
day's shows and then even uh this is
fantastic
I'm really I'm really excited I hope we
kicked this off because imagine we just
have a schedule for the different shops
so we'll have our coffee shop and then
we'll have the franchise agreement which
says you will like we will send you a
list of shows to play on the TVs or we
create our own feed which we then load
the playlist into so all you have to do
is turn the TV on
and then at uh what is what Crowder does
10 a.m right 10 a.m live yes every time
someone like it's it's that simple
Crowders at 10 A.M we we go through a
live stream schedule of everybody's
shows so just like TV you will come in
and you will see a certain show and then
for times when there's nothing nothing
live we can do a program where it's like
we will show James O'Keefe's latest
reports or whatever OMG and then what
happens is it's very very simple
John Smith walks into the coffee shop
and says yeah I'll take a uh let's do a
mocha latte and I'll get a croissant and
then he's sitting there waiting for the
latte they hand him the croissant and
he's like tearing up a piece and
munching and he looks up at the TV and
there is you know uh Viva via fry and
he's and he's saying this is the
original video that was posted by what's
the guy's name Anthony Bass the baseball
player I don't know here's the baseball
player who apologized says he needs to
be re-educated and here's what he said
and the guy's sitting there going like
oh I didn't know that then that dude
goes to work and he sees his buddy at
the water cooler and he's like how's it
going Jim he's like hey John how's it
going he's like what's up nothing yeah
would you get a chance to check out the
game no I didn't but did you hear about
that baseball player who's apparently
apologizing for something those
conversations will exist because
throughout the day people are seeing
that content so we're creating physical
vectors by which people will consume all
of our content and it will create
massive cultural influence the best
coffee shops everyone agrees yes
insert name here says Tim the world
actually ended in 1998 when the
Undertaker threw mankind three stories
during Hell in a Cell
I heard that yeah that's a good one
purple says CBC running ads before
timcast but I'm loyal to cast Brew go
nuggets we're gonna do commercials the
only promotion we have for Casper is
this show but we're going to sponsor
other shows we're going to do ads we
have commercial ideas my commercial idea
is just a guy like it's you're gonna
love it okay it's a guy and he's
sleeping and then all of a sudden you
see Roberto Jr on his nightstand like
Crow and he wakes up and shakes he's
like and then he'll like cowering he
like gets up and he hurries with like
bags under sides to the kitchen he's
shaking and then he like he's scooping
coffee into the bag and then he looks
around and then also you hear the scream
again from Roberto Jr
and then he pours the coffee and then
it's going and then Roberto Jude is like
staring at him and then he pours the
coffee and then he's looking and they
starts drinking it and then all of a
sudden Roberto Jr gets real close
drinking drink and then it just says buy
Casper coffee like this that's the only
message so just like a guy being
terrorized by a rooster I just think
it's really funny that's a good one I
would buy that coffee so hard we have a
bunch of funny ideas too we're just
gonna make really weird videos so that
people are like what did I just watch
and that's kind of the point so you
remember like I saw this weird
commercial it's coffee I guess that's
what makes people remember yeah it is
actually they show like the the most
memorable like Super Bowl ads are the
ones that make people laugh that have
nothing to do with the actual ideas like
at the end it's like Nissan
what does that have to do with Nissan
yeah and then like after the guys all
terrorize just plays like really light
elevator music or whatever and it's like
dude
caspercoffee.com like promo code
ironically Budweiser used to be the king
of that yeah oh yeah yeah
the frogs Yeah
Tom Wolf says Maga versus I've fallen
and I can't get up no that was mean poor
Biden
but you know to be honest
we we should tell people about that but
I do think you'll win more friends by
not being mean about it like if you go
to someone and say look did you see that
video of the dude falling over like and
if they say oh they just tripped to
something else like okay come on man he
fell up the stairs several times he's
fallen several times like let's be real
about the man's health he is not ready
for this
take anybody else and I would say to
people who are like I hate Trump and
hate Republicans I'd be like okay vote
booty judge like I got to be honest like
if we can't agree on politics can we
agree that Biden can't do this anymore
vote for commonly you're like Kamala I
don't like her you can like her but
please not Joe Biden it's sad now yeah
it's just too serious yeah
he's like a low-hanging fruit at this
point it's just not yeah
it's hard
let's grab some more super jets
Lucy Liu says look at the bottom of
Biden's shoes special grip Soul shoes
yeah it's true is that true I mean it's
like a lot a lot of like Dread modern
dress shoes have like a grip pattern
underneath them now so it's not really
like his special shoes on yeah it is to
prevent him from sliding down an airport
ramp because he can't have that yeah I
wonder if he's still walking gingerly
down the airport ramp that's wet another
I think you might have twisted his left
foot like his left foot didn't turn
because it has such strong grip and then
he twisted and fell off possible yeah I
was legit worried he was gonna break
bones yeah yeah that's well the other
thing a lot of people who break hips
elderly people break hips they actually
break the hip before they fall and that
causes them
their hip just like breaks it's
osteoporosis you know in an old age and
that's what happens yeah so that's yeah
I was talking to somebody considering
what happened when Joe Biden was
grabbing his dog's tail after getting
out of the shower yeah the hairline
fracture yeah
reading about it right now yeah man he's
okay right there's been as they've
released a statement like I mean yeah
he's totally fine no no no no no no I
mean just after this fall he got up he
seemed like after he was up he was good
you know but that the lion says you guys
talking about States making their own
money and asking why no one has you
should look into the gold backs in Utah
it's legal tender there are also
Regional local currency Ithaca hours
Ithaca hours aren't very uh much in
circulation these days and I actually
have a a bit of the Utah goldbeck I have
a bunch of them they're cool they're
gold foil bills yeah so there's actually
it's like one one thousandth of a troy
ounce they gave some away at Freedom
fest last year so I have a couple of
them I got it I got I gotta I got a
stack yeah they're like more of that
they're worth a couple bucks I think
they're worth like three bucks I've got
like a couple hundred bucks worth uh
Ithaca hours I was I I always loved that
story Ithaca New York printed their own
currency and it revitalized the
community because people were able to
trade with each other even if US Dollars
weren't around when I visited there a
few years ago I asked somewhat local
businesses and they were like oh yeah
like nobody uses them and I was like
that's sad I guess because the guy who
made it moved or something and nobody
cared anymore so there you go
yeah Coco uh Coco medetta says Utah's
local currency research Utah gold backs
I've got some downstairs they're cool
looking yeah
gold foil bills
Delamar says Ella Irwin has resigned
from Twitter as head of trust and safety
was only got censored on release on the
platform that's right it was releasing
today so did it actually go live no
they're gonna do it tomorrow is it
tomorrow no it's up oh they put it yeah
elon's but it's not like they were doing
it tomorrow no uh Jeremy boring posted
it okay uh did the daily wire posted it
and it got censored immediately okay all
right yep because elon's tweets though
they're not gonna fix it till tomorrow
and it's only supposed to run for like
12 hours all right I see yep
so hopefully they get their whole 12
hours yeah Stuart Brown says Article 1
Section 10 Clause one of the
Constitution says no State shall coin
money or emit bills of credit
what
you want to Google it yeah
[Music]
Druid Arrow says federal government gets
paid through Appropriations States pay
this to the federal government States
collect tax to support itself and then
pay Appropriations tax people only pay
excises taxed the federal government IRS
is a sham yeah and the Fed
purples it sounds like Elon plays Dumb
very interesting
OMG puppy says the new CEO won't start
for a month or more she's still wrapping
up at NBC Elon was in Shanghai China
today I don't think he was in the room
well they might have been on a on a call
and Elon was not listening when they
were like okay we're gonna do this
everybody everything's clear elon's
there but he's not present that could
have been possible yeah because
everything's done over like teams and
zoom and everything anyways yeah so in
the room is a vague term yeah
Cove 12x12s a 12x12 says I want to see a
deep fake of Trump's face on Keanu
Reeves body in the last scene of The
Devil's Advocate it would be the only
honest creative piece we could see on
the internet a great episode guys
okay thank you yeah
Nate Slocum says Bud Light is not free
15 sale than a 15 rebate is still a 15
sale they're cheating the base sales
numbers with giveaways exactly wow they
they want to be able to say our sales
are back up so when they say it's down
30 it's probably down 40. or more I
can't I've not I have too many people
saying nobody's buying we've had too
many people go to local bars and be like
the bars the bar saying they don't sell
it anymore yeah so what's likely
happening is there are people who don't
care who are like 15 bucks and you're
gonna give me 50 bucks back right now
okay I'll do it then they can be like
aha we sold beer
and then there's restaurants I know
people who don't care who just buy it
not paying attention and are wondering
why it's not moving
yeah I was up in Michigan visiting
family for my sister's wedding a couple
weeks ago and it was the same thing like
we would go into bars and everything
would be out and then Bud Light was full
like it was like everybody was all the
other people can't keep up with the
demand because of Bud Light yeah all
right amenthe says we got our shipment
of lifeless gray Pride branded Skittles
at my work today some bags say black
Trans lives matter I'm so tired of this
nonsense
so Skittles is still doing their white
pride Skittles
the all-white ones oh yeah because only
one rainbow matters so they're making
white pride Skittles yeah they always
make the all white they are Pride
Skittles yeah and they're white so
they're white pride Skittles
outstanding
that's so weird it's because they have
to do something during pride month
every other month
they've been in this for a while a lot
of people pointed out that like you made
white pride Skittles and it's kind of
like a joke now and they're still doing
it apparently
well okay I thought they I thought they
got rid of that within the first like
month or the first 10 minutes of them
doing it you know I mean
Tetris says Tim I live in LA county and
work in restaurants Bud sales have
dropped so much that we're no longer
offering it for drinking only used in
the food I'll stop buying it all
together why do you have it
I guess you know what's going to happen
it's going to become it's going to be
it's going to get labeled beer they're
going to get rid of the bud light
branding it's going to be called like
stock beer and it'll be sold at like
discount outlets for a dollar a case to
just move it before it expires and it'll
be sold to restaurants as an ingredient
they'll be like well if you're doing
like beer battering or you know any kind
of beer ingredient here just use this
before then you'll have to boycott the
restaurant yeah because even just to
Rebrand they would that's a that's
another rebranding cost so you have to
get name recognition now out of your new
brand so you're never going to get it to
where Bud Light was oh this is big news
Will I Am says Yingling now available in
the west some liquor stores Wichita
Kansas dropped bud and now stocking
Yingling drinking one right now it's
good yeah that's good stuff yeah yeah
it's the America's oldest brewery it's
it's very big in like I think
Pennsylvania area around here everywhere
you go around here that's like what
everybody drinks yep it's good it's good
I'm not a big Beer Guy you know
Thomas TJ G says Starbucks Nitro cold
brew cans only hold 9.7 ounces not a
full 12 ounce there's a tiny object in
the can to make it feel and look like a
full can probably how they cover the
cost that's the Nitro cartridge and they
probably it's it's yeah so they want to
do standard can uh standard size cans
and to get the Nitro they have to have
the little cartridge so when you open it
it sprays the Nitro into it that
probably makes it a lot cheaper for them
but they're expensive what are they like
four bucks a can or something something
like that yeah that's not easy to do
yeah that would be an example of when to
take investment potentially for the
coffee company because if you could
raise 100 billion dollars and then sell
the beer for a dollar cheaper and then
just start the process not the beer at
the coffee for a dollar cheaper well I
mean it's not that if we if we received
like an order for a million cans
we would order the million cans so but
that's like getting to that point is
hard and right now we're an online store
so what we really need to do is we need
our own coffee shop open so that we can
start stocking around products it's
under construction there's a lot of work
it's got to get done we need I mean if
we have a bunch of franchises and
they're all selling the same product
then we're gonna start moving a ton we
want to do we want to get the coffee in
gas stations we want to get it in local
convenience stores
but we'll get there we'll get there is
there examples of the company spinning
up
um would you call them where people open
their own franchises franchises uh
without a base location like you don't
need to you could just open franchises
all over without having a we have to we
have to create the the protocols the
parameters the strategies of the first
location so we know what we what we want
to be
we want people to have a similar
experience we want people to be like oh
let's go to let's go find a cast Brew
just like people say where's the
Starbucks we want people to pull up
their app and look for a cast brew and
we want to exude cultural influence
that's the plan
um maybe what we need to do is we need
to find somebody who's like a high level
uh Regional director or manager at a big
coffee chain who wants to launch a new
project and then have them just like
start up the process and spin it up and
create the protocol and then we could
have some like once they create the
general plan the art we could just have
people start spinning up caspers all
over the place yeah people have been
contacting me they're ready
I'm out let's do it I don't know let's
just get them going it'll be great
but they need parameters well we we we
want
like we want TVs in these places we want
it to be that people are getting exposed
to
this kind of content so we we need to
build in the centralized Hub the feed so
someone like it's like hey open this URL
on on all the TVs or like on the
computer and then plug in the HDMI and
press play and then we will have like
every day we'll show you the list of
shows we're going to be playing and
things like that so we can have a like a
uniformed experience for people
that way you know someone goes to Casper
and they're like oh Casper sells this
product they know that they can go to
any location and get the thing they like
we gotta figure it out free internet
okay find the correction on coining
money it's they can issue receipts or uh
uh receipts coupons they can issue
coupons but not money not money coupons
yes that was my mistake I mixed that how
does that work what's a coupon a state
could issue I'm not sure this is like
I'm having a lot of cognitive dissonance
right now because I learned that they
could like I've never fact checked it
because I just learned that they could
I'd imagine it'd be like you could like
use a coupon to claim gold or silver
yeah yeah something like that I I don't
I'll have to dig into it yeah this is
this is this is crazy Sparky says a good
example when I bottle my homegrown hot
sauce to give to friends and relatives
it's much cheaper for me to buy bottles
of hot sauce and empty them than to buy
empty bottles what this world man it's
awesome
yep but it's because they can erase the
cost of the bottle if they can sell
enough
like if man if you're if you're selling
a hundred million bottles of something
your penny profit turns you a million
bucks you know it's like the the
variability of an empty bottle the value
of being able to put whatever you want
into it is greater than the value of the
product inside the bottle when you can
only sell one send one thing so that's a
good question how many home Brewers are
going to buy Bud Light at the rebate
with the 15 rebate just to empty the
beer out so they can put their home
brews instead of buying their actual no
yeah there's gonna be a bottling sales
company now yeah
at zero zero percent markup because
they're giving the product away right
now
that's actually if you're if you're a
home Brewer it's like go get go get Bud
Light and just pour it out and put your
stuff in it Sparky says when there are a
lot of short positions on a stock it
props up the stock price because it
creates a shortage of shares called a
short squeeze
interesting but that's also a move
intentionally done when someone's
shorting a stock right like if someone
if you know a group is gonna try and
short a stock you can buy it up
massively and then hopefully wait it out
so they're forced to buy at a higher
price yeah something like that just like
yeah did they do that with they did
something like that with GameStop I
think yeah yeah there were a bunch of
shorts on it and then all of the meme
buyers bought it up driving the price up
and that just destroyed these these
these uh these firms it ruined their put
options yep all of a sudden they had to
pay a ton of money out yep man
what do we got Brian infatch says in
League of Legends LCS team CLG was
sponsored by Bud Light doing BTS videos
and they blunded a video by writing the
Players called it called Bud Light
beheading
huh no no
digital shade says I bet Dylan shorted
inbev that'd be funny yeah
short Nike too
it's interesting you know what I think
it is the thing about Bud Light is that
it's a fast perishable product the
challenge with Nike is that people own
things they're going to wear for years
and so you're gonna see him wearing it
they might not buy something now
you know but that's why and when all
that's even happened I was like you know
I use I usually born primitive and other
stuff for workout gear I don't even use
like these big companies for almost
anything anymore alcohol I buy local
companies my big thing is a bank I don't
know I'd love to get into like a local
bank but I've been in I don't want Wells
Fargo I don't know if it matters but
that's where I've been and then you have
like companies like Alexa athletica they
have leggings that you can put a gun in
so they have gun holsters in their
leggings which is pretty cool
so many new companies coming out the
last four or five years pretty cool
and they're so why would you even
support some of these big companies I'd
rather support the local guy yeah we got
to figure it out but we're gonna we're
gonna take over with cast Brew Coffee
we've got some really cool stuff in the
works K-Cups are coming and uh I've
we've we've heavily invested a lot and
we're getting to the point where it's
like okay we gotta aren't making that
money back because just putting money
into it so it has to it needs breathing
room I do think it's possible if we if
we found somebody who had experience
with you know National level franchising
and product sales and stuff like that
that we could with the size of our
audience instantly have a very very big
product
and uh but for the time being where
we're at is we order some we sell it we
order a little bit more and we're trying
to find that point of equilibrium so
with that being said we're about to go
to that members only show smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to timcast.com click join us to join the
Discord server and talk with like-minded
individuals and hang out in our members
only uncensored show which will be on
the front page in a few minutes you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast Sarah do
you want to shout anything out yeah just
follow me at YouTube it's just uh
youtube.com
rumbles the same rumble.com Sarah Higdon
Sarah Higdon on with an underscore on
Instagram and Twitter and
um yeah and then go check out
um the post-millennial obviously and
check it and I'm doing uh Freedom Fest
this year so um that's coming up in July
so go get your tickets it's gonna be in
Memphis this year cool
all right you can find me Josie the
redhead libertarian at trhl official on
Twitter
um I I do a lot of different stuff but
that's really the place that I I hang
out the most uh and I tune into my
spaces when I do those there's some some
big things coming up follow me at Ian
Crossland Ian crossland.net anywhere
else and special thoughts and prayers
for Jamie Foxx love you man keep well
breathe easy we got you and you can see
me arguing with gripers on Twitter and
help me out because I'm not a fan so
I'll see you guys around it's at
surf.com we will see you all over at
timcast.com in a couple minutes thanks
for hanging out